Hello 大家好，我是小俊。
AI业界有两个摇顺语，一个从Open Eye跳槽到了騰训，一个从Enthropic跳槽到了Google DeepMind。
前一位摇顺语去年来过我们节目，那今天我们邀请了另外一位。
这类摇顺语毕业于清华和斯坦福大师，
曾经的研究方向包括非热米系统、量子物理和高能物理。
毕业后从物理转战AI，
2024年加入Enthropic,。
2025年跳槽到了Google DeepMind出任研究科学家，
参与了Cloud 3.7 4.5 Gemini 3 等模型的开发过程。
那除了这些重点模型的开发之外，
它有一些很有趣的观点，比如说AI的本质是简单的，
预设认也是一种强化学习，不要明显老登。
AI个人英雄主义的时代已经过去了，
AI从业者最重要的特质是靠谱等等。
我们的节目录制于2026年3月，
距离我们这次节目录制完，
世界又发生了许多意想不到的变化，
比如说Mata对于Minus的收购被撤销，
Cursor可能被SpecSax收购，
XAI将终止独立运营并入SpecSax，
并且更名为SpecSaxAI等等。
那如果我们的谈话内容有一定的智候性，
还请大家能够多多包涵，
因为AI的世界实在是变化太快也太出乎意料了。
那可能还要特别说明的一点是，
技术细节会涉及到一些企业机密，
有一些是嘉宾不方便分享的，
所以也请大家能够多多包容，
我们在最大的可能的范围内，
和大家一起来学习AI。
那接下来就是我对顺语的访谈，
期待2026年，我们和AI共同进步。
Mata作为一个公司来说，
它能够实现这种就是比较Top Down的机制，
是一个很独特的事。
这对于家模型公司很难吗？
很难，比如说OPPA就干不了，
就是Gemna也比较难，
打公司和STARTOP，
它打发本来就不一样，
因为STARTOP重要的是make that，
就是我得赌一件事，
我觉得大家现在就是，
每个人都是冲浪的人，
本质上是一个浪，
而不是你那个冲浪的人，
因为AI这个事本来也不太需要脑子。
真的不太需要脑子。
需要什么？
我觉得这个行业就是最重要的特质，
就是copy,
就是做事儿戏，
然后对自己做的事负责任，
这是最重要的特质。
桂谷不是有两个摇顺语吗？
你要不要先给大家介绍一下你自己，
然后给大家copy一下两个摇顺语的区别？
可以，对，就是我叫摇顺语，
然后显然有一个跟我几乎同名的朋友，
然后我们俩主要履历也有一些overlap，
所以说可能看起来非常的难以区分，
然后我以前是做学物理的，
然后我本科的时候在清华，
那时候做音音态理论，
然后后来去斯坦福做理论高能物理，
然后和量子信息黑洞相关的一些方面，
然后离开斯坦福之后，
去伯克利短暂地待了两个星期的Postdoc，
然后就离职去了Anzopic，
然后在Anzopic待了一年，
去年9月底10月初的时候加入了Gemini，
然后如果大家非要区分的话，
我觉得最大的区分就是那个顺与他一开始，
就是一直都是做CS，就是计算机相关的，
然后我其实从某种意义上来说是个半道出家，
我之前是做理论物理为主的，
你们是不是好朋友，
你们好像大学就认识了，而且是一级的，对吧，
他是一个什么样的人，你是一个什么样的人，
评价一下他，你也评价一下自己。
对对对，我们本科就认识，
因为我们本科是一级的，然后在清华，
但他一开始就是学计算机的嘛，
所以他在那个摇班就是计算机科学实验班，
然后我学物理，所以我在计科班，
对，然后后来他去了普林，我去斯坦福，
这可能也是另一个有点肺节的点，
好像这个普世世界里觉得斯坦福。
应该是学计算机的人该去的地方，
然后觉得普林斯顿是学物理人该去的地方，
但我俩然后反过来，
所以说也可能产生了一些肺节的事情，对，
然后我俩其实也还真的挺不一样，
我觉得他是一个比我有趣的多的人，
我觉得我从他身上也是，
在过去也是能学习到了一些。
后很不一样的点，
比如说他可能花了很多时间去思考，
比如在AI方面，他花的时间去思考。
就是人和AI的交互呀，
然后包括一些产品上的事情，
然后我觉得对我来说是一个很不一样的朋友，
然后我也从他那儿学到了很多东西，
你们之前在硅谷的时候多久见一次面，
你们现在是不是还频繁打电话，多频繁？
我们在硅谷的时候见面确实挺频繁的，
可能每几个星期，
但是好像见面主要是为了凑一块玩，
玩啥?
就是真的就是纯玩，
就是可能出去散散步，
车车有的没的，
然后可能有时候吃个饭打个牌之类的，
对，然后他回去之后，
其实我们也也是经常会打电话，
最近是电话聊事儿了，
好像就是前一两个星期，
你怎么知道的，
可能就是会过几个月，
然后就开始回家，
大家最近的情况，
他是不是多次想把你拉过去？
可能有这个意思，
但是我觉得不关键，
你为什么不去？
我觉得对我自己来说，
我没想清楚，
我觉得多半是我自己的原因，
然后我也没有去任何中国的地方，
然后我觉得主要原因是因为，
在去年的9月或者89月这个时候，
我觉得那时候我离开了Sophic，
然后离开之后决定要去哪儿的时候，
最大的动机是，
我想学一些不一样的东西，
对我来说，
我可能就没有去考虑，
没有更着重的去考虑说，
能够去领导一个项目，
或者领导一个project之类的，
我更多的是，
那个时候更多的是，
优先去学习这些东西，
所以那个时候选择去了Germany，
对,
我把你们两个老被放在一起比较和讨论，
对你来说是困扰更多，
还是享受更多？
我没什么感觉，
然后因为我这个人也不太关注社交媒体，
所以我其实真的没什么感觉。
因为那个顺语，
他之前在去年的时候说，
AI进入了the second half,。
进入了下半场，
成为了一个非常有名的观点，
你觉得今天的AI在一个什么样的时期，
你能给他一个定义吗？
对,
我觉得对我来说，
我可能看的没有那么清楚，
什么叫做上半场，
什么叫做下半场，
这个定义一直以来对我并不是特别清楚。
对我来说，
确实现在AI进入到了一个阶段，
我觉得大家都已经开始不那么担心一件事，
AI是不是能够做得到，
而是担心这件事是不是被良好定义？
对,
我觉得这是一个很大的区别。
比如说，
我觉得一年之前，
就是可能去年年初的时候，
那时候，
我在哪里逃避，
然后大家可能担心的事情还是说，
哎,
OpenAI这个reasoning做得这么强，
有没有机会能够追上，
然后有多大的机会能够超越他，
大家还很担心这个事，
我觉得现在就是在任何，
至少在OpenAI和Ensobre这三家当中，
我觉得没有哪一家，
会真的担心自己追不上，
然后我觉得可能现在对大家更难，
那事情是想明白要去做什么，
这个是一个，
我觉得是一个bat，
是一个赌，
但是也是，
我觉得也是一个很需要人的inside的事情，
对,
那这也意味着模型的能力被拉平了，
对不对，
它变得同质化，
变得商品化，
所以模型没有很大的区别，
就是在好坏上没有很大的区别，
但是它需要风化，
我觉得从用户的实际体验上来说，
这三家模型是能够感受到区别的，
但是,
难的一点是过去这个区别，
在纸面上也能看出来，
在纸面上，
纸面上是指，
就是比如说像公开的有很多这种板尺码，
这种测量的规范，
然后比如说大家以前能够去看sv-bench，
对对对，
能看sv-bench,。
然后可能数学大家那时候会比，
像简单一点的ami，
ami,
然后难一点的像m，
那个时候我感觉就是，
你从纸面上就能看出来，
哎,
这个模型好像reasoning强一点，
那个模型好像coding强一点，
那个模型这个强一点，
现在就是纸面上大家其实都比较相近，
当然你去看那个纸面上的消息，
比如看sv-bench，
你会发现哎，
好像好的会比不好的可能高一个百分点，
或者两个百分点，
但其实大家都在80%附近，
那个附近数字高一点，
低一点，
其实是主要是noise，
主要是造声，
而不是信号，
对,
但是从另一方面来说，
大家使用上确实还是能体现出区别的，
我觉得，
就我个人了解到的信息而言，
Cloud目前仍然是比较通用的，
这种工具使用类的agent表现最好的，
然后在纯粹coding的方面，
可能最近codex稍微追上了地点，
把这个中间的概率变小了一点，
然后diamondite可能在纯的reasoning，
然后和一些比较日常的使用环境下，
可能目前还是比较好的，
然后在coding和agent上，
还处于一个比较在接近的这个状态，
对,
这些能力他们是有意选择，
我优先发展哪个方向，
还是说它就是好和坏的区别，
就是它是能力问题还是意愿问题？
我觉得，
其实是有意愿的成分在的，
尤其在过去的情况下，
主要是意愿，
就是当大家能从纸面上，
就看出区别的仇，
那时候意愿肯定是占大多数的，
因为可能像Cloud就一直更看重，
这种使用工具的能力，
然后包括coding，
那可能OPI有一段时间非常看重reasoning，
对，当然现在开始看重coding了，
那时候肯定是意愿会占大多数，
因为你更有意愿的话，
就意味着你能花更多的精力去。
构建合适的技术设施，
合适的infra，
构建合适的数据，
然后尤其数据它是一个，
从某种理上来说，
很花时间很花精力的事情，
对,
虽说那个时候肯定是意愿专注到，
现在这个时候，
我觉得两方面其实都有，
因为其实，
因为纸面都看起来差不多，
然后其实甚至你就做一些。
更内部的测试来说，
这个数字也都变得，
差别没有那么大了，
然后这时候更难的事情就是，
你该怎么去定义的问题，
定义你想要的行为，
然后在这个事情没有定义得那么清楚的时候，
模型的很多差异其实来自于一些，
其实是你想象不到的事，
对,
想象不到的是指的是？
我觉得，
当然想象不到的事就是，
你现在去问，
其实我很难给你一个特别亲属的答案，
可能过一段时间之后，
回过头来看我才能给一个亲属的答案，
但是我可以举一个，
想象不到的例子吧，
就是比如说，
比如说摧毁，往回摧毁，
可能一年两年，
甚至三年的时候，
那时候如果你比如说去网上，
取这些预讯链的数据的话，
你看,
训言一个模型就会发现，
模型在写代码，
那时候当然没有这种。
A占这个的写代码，
它都是写一段代码，
那时候你会发现，
模型的话写代码会写得很好，
但是,
可能那时候大家不知道为什么，
这个里面意外的原因可能就是，
你从网上随便去，
如果不做任何的，
数据的筛选的话，
那自然的这个，
这个code的data的质量，
就会比别的高一点，
因为你去看网页，
也会发现getup的质量，
是显著比别的，
正常网也要高，
那在近日我们今天主题之前，
我想先聊聊我们最近模型的，
一系列的静闻，
就是,
你看最近大家都在考论opencloud，
你作为一线的研究员，
你对这个新的产品形态，
是怎么看的，
你周围有哪些讨论？
我觉得，
有趣的是，
我感觉这个事情在，
业外的讨论，
好像比业内的讨论更激烈，
业内没有人讨论？
业内有人讨论，
但是,
我觉得对业内的人来说，
他并不是一个，
嗯,
特别令人惊讶的事，
我怎么说？
就是,
可能在公司内部也有人，
已经做了，
类似的，
这种,
这种实验，
或者这种demo，
只是可能并没有作为一个，
产品,
去很认真的宣发，
然后把它打磨，
然后发出去，
对，然后，
当然是情况就是，
你去看这个opencloud，
最早版本的github的那个code，
其实那个code也就，
呃,
从某种意义下说，
写的也不是特别的干净，
但是我觉得他很重要的事，
是他,
呃,
给大家展示了这种可能性，
嗯,
那可能，
展示这种可能性之后，
未来,
呃,
想看opencloud,。
作者自己也加入了，
然后那可能就是，
呃,
模型的，
的实验室，
或者说一些，
呃,
大一辆创业公司，
会很快跟上，
然后把这东西打磨成，
一个真正可用的产品，
其实在opencloud发布之前，
Google就已经有人在做这个事情了，
只是还没有发布，
因为大公司的流程比较长。
对，我，我，我，我的，
我至少我个人，
呃,
所,
所得到的印象是这样的，
所看到的是这样，对。
所以这种类opencloud的这种产品型，
他也背后，
他本身说明了什么，
在今年初的这个实验店上？
我觉得，
其实,
呃,
我觉得，
基本上来说，
其实并不能说明什么，
就是说，
opencloud这个,。
这个产品，
当然他依赖于，
模型能做的很多事情，
但是那些事情的能力，
其实并不是到今年，
年初才，
准备充足，
我觉得可能，
在去年，
就是像opus，
发布4.5,
然后,
呃,
当然那时候opus，
其实比opencloud,。
和gambler3,。
在toyuse能力上，
都要强一些，
所以我觉得，
在那个实验店，
其实你做这个事，
这个事，
就已经是可以展示出来的，
然后其实他，
他,
过一段时间，
才活起来，
所以说，
呃,
我觉得可能，
对我来说，
技术上，
他并不是一个，
呃,
并不是一个，
就说,
那么令人惊讶的事，
他是模型能力的自然一处，
对,
我会这样觉得，
但是我觉得他可能，
一个,
对于大家的惊喜，
是说,
以前可能大家都没有意识到，
嗯,
他让大家意识到的，
这件事可以做，
意识到什么？
就意识到了这个，
你可以，
让模型做很，
就是,
你会做会总之后，
做一个很长很长，
很长,
老horizon的这种，
这种工作，
我觉得可能，
呃，以前，
大家并没有，
并没有广泛的，
对这个事产生共识，
那这个事情，
呃,
给大家展示了，
这样一种狠的性吗？
对,
你看,
从去年出火的是minus，
今年出火的是opencloud，
就是从minus的opencloud变化是什么？
是模型能力的变化，
还是产品的变化？
这也是一个，
我其实一直没理解的事，
嗯,
就是,
呃,
minus和opencloud之间的,。
质的区别是什么？
是一个我其实自己没看，
没太看明白的事情，
说实话，
呵呵呵，
OK,
嗯,
就是,
或者换句话说，
可能,
opencloud这个事,。
火了,
但是,
如果你要回头问我说，
为什么minus做不了这个事，
我不明白minus，
为什么做不了，
嗯,
可能只是他没做，
对,
但是你看，
不管是minus，
他们都选择了minus，
卖给了mita，
opencloud,。
卖给了openi，
这个形象说明，
说明什么呢？
为什么他们都卖了？
我觉得，
呃,
我自己的，
我自己的感受是，
一个东西，
如果要，
呃,
长久的生存，
还是需要考虑一些壁垒的？
壁垒是模型？
呃,
我觉得，
至少目前，
来说,
很多壁垒都在模型测，
但是未来，
会不会产生产品测的壁垒，
我觉得是说不，
说不定的，
就,
因为大家，
市场上，
就是这个都老生常谈的话题，
就很多人，
就谈论这些什么，
数据费轮啊，
之类的事情，
呃,
目前来说，
我觉得，
没有哪一个，
长进啊，
真正的，
形成了数据费轮，
甚至,
AI,
纯粹原生的，
应用长进，
我觉得目前，
除了,
AISAN这个coding,。
就是写代码之外，
没有哪个长进，
是AI真正原生的长进，
变得非常成功，
因为从某种意义上来说，
插Bot,
其实是搜索的一个延伸，
插Bot是搜索延伸，
对,
它为什么不是独立于搜索呢？
它是,
因为,
你想,
大家其实和插Bot，
最多的，
交互,
是,
我有一个问题，
就问这个插Bot，
然后,
这个其实是搜索本来干的事，
但是,
它带来的，
比搜索要，
远强的一个事情，
是,
它变得非常interactive，
就是,
它有交互性，
你可以追问，
然后,
你决出一些，
通过它或许的一些，
一些信息，
帮你把它压缩成，
能缩成，
回答你的问题的那个信息，
对,
这个是以前搜索，
给不了你的，
对,
但它,
当然,
就不是完全一样的需求，
但是从，
从需求，
从大的需求上来说，
是比较类似于搜索之前的需求，
minus open cloud,。
我觉得，
都是现在最有名的壳，
但是壳最后都卖给了模型，
那是不是说明壳，
还是难以逃脱，
模型的长型，
这个逃应速度不够快，
是不是？
我觉得，
我觉得壳，
在目前这个情况下，
活海来有，
有两种我，
我大概能想象的方式，
一种想象的方式，
就是像你刚才说的，
逃的足够快，
就是,
我增长速度足够快，
以至于在模型公司，
反应过来的时候，
我其实已经占领了，
大量用户薪质，
然后,
在模型公司追你，
产品形态的时候，
我又自己演发出了自己的模型，
我觉得，
Cursor就是试图在走这条路，
那,
Cursor其实,。
在这种AI原生场景下，
几乎是我能想到的，
串业公司也增长得最快的，
就算这样的公司，
它现在也很有危机感，
它有多有危机感？
反正,
我的感觉是，
对Cursor来说，
现在,
Cursor这个已经进入了一个，
非常微妙的关系，
就是,
曾经他们是，
亲密无见的合作伙伴，
Cursor提供模型，
Cursor提供产品，
后来,
Cursor自己有了可捞扣子，
可捞扣子现在变得非常成功，
然后Cursor现在又自己，
是做自己的模型，
所以Cursor在努力的，
训策的composer，
所以说，
我觉得，
都不用说为，
其实现在就，
他们已经处于一种，
比较竞争的关系了，
那,
如果,
在竞争中输掉的话，
我觉得是比较麻烦的，
因为,
代码这个事情，
Coding这个事情，
其实,
它本身是一种，
服务与专业用户的专业需求，
是一种效率工具，
效率工具，
很容易出现的一个场景，
就是,
赢家通吃，
我觉得这个是，
不管对Cursor还是对，
Cursor还是对，
对任何人做Coding的公司来说，
可能都是他们比较担心的事，
对,
然后,
这是刚才说的，
就是一条路，
就是,
这个市场够快，
你在,
别人还没想吃你的时候，
就疯狂涨，
等他想吃你说，
已经足够大，
另一种方式，
就是,
这市场足够的小，
小到模型公司，
根本懒得去管，
我觉得，
Made journey,。
就是这个意思，
就是这个，
这个市场，
小到,
可能,
虽然你说，
咱们来努力吧，
能不能做Made journey,。
那个事，
可能,
花一些经理，
花一些钱，
花一些data，
是能做到的，
那就,
不是很会，
在那时候呢，
花时间了，
看不上，
对,
我觉得，
那可能也是一种，
活下去的方式，
对,
所以,
哪怕是Cursor，
今天也没有，
讨议出，
模型的，
手掌型，
有谁成功，
讨议了吗？
Made journey,。
我觉得，
大的就，
我目前还没看到，
小的可能，
Made journey,。
这个例子，
当然,
肯定有别的例子，
我觉得，
他们有机会，
对,
反正就，
不能做那种，
通用的场景，
我觉得，
就是,
这是Founder要，
自己要，
要决定的件事，
就是,
你要不要，
抱着,
万分之一的，
生存纪律，
去赌一票大的，
还是,
抱着,
百分之一的，
生存纪律，
去先吃另一个，
小的事情，
如果是你，
你会怎么选？
如果是我，
我内心，
肯定是想，
吃一票大的，
但是我，
真诚的想，
是,
我觉得，
第一步是，
不能一步等天，
所以,
如果是我，
我会选择，
去吃一个，
先吃一个小的，
但是,
我会选择一个，
有,
想象空间的，
小的,
你说,
Open Cloud,。
Mata,
Google,
买了Windserve的人，
OK,
Windserve,。
我不理解.
说实话，
就是,
我不理解，
我觉得，
我想,
Mata,
买Manus这个事，
我觉得，
对他们来说，
最大的用处，
就是,
如果,
拨掉花了多少钱之外，
这些用处，
是获得了一批.
在亚洲，
很好的在亚洲的产品团队。
在亚洲说明什么？
因为我觉得一方面就是。
现然大家都知道中国的AI人才出轨还是很豐富的。
虽然可能目前从纯技术上来说。
中国的AI还没有真的追上美国。
但是现然中国是有很多好的人的。
不管是从纯技术上还是从产品上。
我觉得可能中国的本质上人才是比美国要更好的。
对
所以对他来说我觉得。
曼诺斯成为了他在新加坡的一个谋点。
他可以从那里吸引一些。
比如说从中国的或者是新加坡或者东亚的人才。
然后我其实没有特别看明白。
这个产品本身对mata来说有多重要。
或者换句话说就是为什么他不能自己干这个产品。
但是不管是mata的时候还是open cloud。
他事实上就是诞生于外面的团队。
为什么不是硅谷的这一帮研究员做出来的呢？
你没有反思过这个问题。
对
我觉得对我来说这样。
这个问题其实
我觉得一个公司一旦变大了之后。
它的负担也变大
就说我可能作为一个研究员。
然后我们可以做一些很有趣很有特点的产品。
但是我一旦把这个产品去公开给公众。
那要负责的事情是非常多的。
第一你这个产品不可能说一上线。
然后告诉所有用户。
你得再去买一台电脑干这个事。
否则他就有可能会获得你电脑上所有的权限。
然后把系统搞崩了。
这就作为一个大公司来说。
你Google是不可能提供这样的产品出去的。
对吧？
然后所以你产品的话。
可能是很多时间打磨。
然后你要确认法律上它没有一些风险。
然后用户上又不会损坏自己的品牌。
然后你如果如果把它送出去了。
你可能还要给它就是比较固定的一些资源。
去serve这个模型或者serve这条产品的线。
所以这大公司虽然说。
我觉得还是有挺多负担。
但是对于个人来说。
无所谓就是我反正是一个开源的项目。
我带马拉基又如何。
你帮我来一起写吧？
对吧？
但是我觉得不管是minus还是open cloud。
它其实指的一个方向。
就是可能这也是2026年的某种叙事的可能性。
你对2026年怎么样思考和预期的。
我觉得其实有太多的可能性。
然后对我来说从模型能力上来说。
我觉得模型就是我有时候特别说这个口号。
我觉得模型做到train with finite context。
use as infinite context。
换句话说
你用有限的context lens去训练它。
但是可以在使用的时候用非常非常长。
甚至接近一部线的context lens。
我觉得这件事今年是有机会能够实现的。
然后这件事情实现之后。
我觉得会解锁很多新的应用。
也会因为举一个最简单的例子。
你有可能可以让这个模型跟你持续的交互。
然后持续的获得你的信息。
然后它在运行的过程中。
会持续的根据当前的场景和你的会话。
可能把那些它觉得不重要的信息扔掉。
然后就成为大家梦想中的个人助手。
对
我觉得从技术上来说。
我觉得这件事今年无论如何是会实现的。
但是当然我觉得现在大家没有达成共识的。
是技术上怎么去实现这个事。
显然是有很多技术路线。
但是现在我觉得更多是处于在尝试哪一条路线。
能够跑通的同时
可能有好几条路线都能跑通。
那我们到时候就要去实验上。
去测在用户常用的使用场景下。
哪条路线的效率是最高的。
对
我觉得现在更多处于这个阶段。
而不是说大家没有想法的结果。
对大家有想法
但是要确定哪个想法是最后的想法。
站在这个2026年的QE。
作为一个一线的研究员。
你觉得模型的进步速度在放缓吗？
我觉得完全没有
完全没有
它的速度曲线对比二五年二四年的变化是什么？
这个很难谅话的
说过因为就是你得给一个标准。
我才能谅话的告诉你。
因为如果你给的标准是。
比如说我就看在某一个班车mark。
比如说随便办事上。
它每一个月涨多少个点。
那这个事是肯定会变慢的。
因为根据定义
这个玩车mark最高就到100%。
所以你越接近那肯定是又跑得越慢。
但是这可能并不代表。
用户体验这个模型的能力。
总长变慢
因为可能从50%到60%。
它可能感觉好了一点。
但很有可能
比如说从70%到75%。
它还好得比50%到60%那个还多。
这是完全有可能
如果是80%到90%。
90%到100%这个感受会更显著。
那也不一定
因为可能过了
可能到80%到90%。
用户就发现没有任何区别。
甚至还变差
你说完全没有变慢。
你是基于什么标准。
我觉得是基于我个人作为一个研究员的感觉。
就是我觉得我个人得到的感受。
是这个模型学东西的能力越来越强。
以前可能让模型学会干一件事情。
需要动很多脑筋
但现在可能不需要动那么多脑筋了。
最重要的事
你是要把这个问题定清楚。
然后想清楚怎么去构建合适的数据。
当然数据现在数据就更快发展。
指向环境之类的都在包括在内了。
然后剩下的事情
好像很多时候是顺其自然的了。
学习能力变强是为什么？
模型的学习能力变强。
我觉得可能一方面。
原因可能会很多风格。
但我觉得可能一方面。
是因为预宣了其实在过去的几个月里。
我觉得还是越来越强了的。
预宣链
对
模型的预宣链其实在过去几个月里还是变强了。
我觉得这个可能是一个。
从某种意义上来说比较有争议的事。
因为几个月以前我觉得。
就是很多人已经在讨论。
预宣链的Scaling Law是不是已经到头了。
我的体验是没有
而且我的感觉是在未来的四个月。
也没有看到到头的迹象。
对
觉得到头是为什么呢？
我觉得
我显然不知道大家觉得到头的原因是什么？
因为我自己没解的到头。
但是我觉得我的猜测是。
一个人觉得一个规律到头了。
无非以下两种情况。
一个情况是
他觉得这个规律的适用范围到头了。
就可能从根本意义上讲。
Scaling Law就是没有办法无穷延展下去的。
维持有可能是对的。
但是这是一种态度。
就是这个人可能觉得这个规律适用范围到头了。
一种可能是这个人觉得。
这个规律其中有一个条件不能满足了。
比如说他觉得数据就已经撞上墙了。
那我完全没有把他延展下去了。
这是另外一种可能性。
但其实还有第三种可能性。
其他可能性就是
其实他这个工作哪里有一个bug。
他自己没发现
所以他觉得到头了。
我觉得从我的观点。
从我的观感上来说。
我觉得可能绝大多数撞到墙的人是因为第三种。
是有bug是哪种bug。
我觉得bug是有很多可能性的。
比如说一种可能性是。
你Scaling Law做的时候。
一些科学的假设没有做对。
说你选什么样的
Token Horizon就是每一个大小的模型。
选什么样的期待的训练的数据量。
然后怎么这个数据是从哪里选。
然后有可能这些比较科学的选择。
没有选清楚是一种可能性。
但我觉得还有种可能性就是纯粹有个bug。
这个其实在业界我觉得也不惊奇。
很多时候修好一个bug带来的进展。
是远大于一些很神奇的技巧的。
对
然后大概还有另外的情况。
我觉得我刚才给了这两种例子。
反正是我见到过比较多的情况。
但你们的bug怎么办。
你们怎么解决bug问题的。
我觉得
我感觉这更像是一个信念的问题。
因为当你遇到一个bug。
你觉得它不能解除。
你就会说这个到头了。
当你遇到个bug。
我觉得这个肯定可以解决。
那你就觉得这还没有到头。
因为肯定每个人都要遇到bug。
对
我觉得这可能
真想说其中有一些比较信念性的东西。
但对我来说更重要的一件事是做事系统。
就是你当你一个事情和你预测的不一样的时候。
你能不能系统性的排除各种可能性。
这个我觉得是一个很重要的事。
这个是我觉得展卖和两条被做的比较好。
就是游戏在预选来什么？
就是说当某一个尺度上的行为。
可能和你想象中不一样的时候。
大家能够去设计合理的我们所谓的ablation实验。
合理的这种实验能够看出来。
测你的一些想象中的可能的因素。
是不是真的因素
我觉得这个做问题的系统性才是关键。
对
你觉得模型能力还能提高。
那它的驱动力数据算力算法。
你觉得它的驱动力主要来源于哪个。
我觉得其实都有
但是从某种意义上来说。
数据和算力两个事其实是很强观点的一件事。
数据和算力
对
因为你算力上去了自然就会吸收更多的数据。
数据上去了你就自然就吸收更多的算力。
然后算法上来说
我觉得算法作用往往是有一个相辨的。
就是算法有一个阶段是你完全没有搞清楚该怎么做。
那个阶段就算法会非常非常关键。
因为你完全没有搞清楚怎么做的时候。
你可能就完全没有办法skill up。
然后可能就卡在那。
但是在某一个点你可能发现了算法当中最重要的一件事。
它可能一下就变成了从完全不能做变成能做。
然后之后算法的提升更多的是一种比较平滑的提升。
就是它可能从某人上提高了你计算的效率或者使用数据的效率。
对
然后我觉得这个举例。
就比如说从原模型的预讯来说。
那可能这个算法上的这个跳的过程。
就是发展出transformer这个事情。
但transformer发发发现之后。
更多的都是慢慢就是平滑的。
让它的效率或者你使用data或者使用算力的效率变得越来越高了。
所以现在的驱动力是算力和数据。
我觉得在现在比较清晰的框架里面。
主要的驱动力是算力和数据。
清晰框架是指比如说预讯链和后讯。
不管是基于强化学的后讯链。
还是基于supervised learning就是监督学习的后讯链。
在这两个就是比较清晰的这种paradigm下。
确实算力和数据是主要的驱动力。
但是不可否认
可能有别的方向可能驱动力失算。
你什么意思
举个简单例子
比如说多么太深层。
那个我觉得可能就是一个算法上来说。
没有太想清楚的事。
对
所以那个还是个科学问题还没有解决。
但是语言已经不是科学问题了。
自然语言的生成
我觉得目前这条技术发案撞到头之前。
我觉得在科学上是比较清楚。
但是工程上还有很多要做的事。
你觉得预讯链还能提高多少。
通过预讯链提升模型能力。
还有多少多长的路可以走。
可以预期到
人就是这样
就是当你没有撞到头的时候。
你其实不知道这个路有多长。
我能看到的就是现在还没撞到头。
但我也不知道哪天会撞到头。
如果真的让我去估计一个时间线的话。
就像刚才说
我觉得四个月
剩下的四个月还是会继续有惊感。
但是AI这个方向没有人能预测四个月之后的事。
所以过去几个月你在看预讯链和模型能力的时候。
你还是很兴奋的
这是你周围的普遍的心态和状态吗？
我觉得是的
这是在Google一个小环境里面。
还是说在整个硅谷的环境里面。
我觉得很难说在整个硅谷。
因为硅谷是个太大的地方。
可能做产品人对产品很兴奋。
做产品来说对他们最兴奋的是可能有分靠。
但是对做模型的人来说。
可能就是我们会对这种模型的进展更兴奋一些。
对
我觉得
在对于做模型的人来说。
兴奋是一个共识吗？
在过去四个月
我更认为是的
至少在我能接触到的范围内。
我觉得在Athelware和Google大家。
大家可能想的更多的是。
我们AI会不断的进展下去。
很快我们就要被替代掉。
替代掉之后我们该干点啥。
而不是模型撞到头了。
该怎么办
说到这个问题
为什么在过去几个月。
coding的发展速度是最快的。
为什么是这个场景。
我觉得coding这个场景。
首先coding这个事。
观众是过去几个月发展最快。
我觉得coding这个事。
其实从Cloud3.5new。
外界有人关键
coding3.6。
从那个之后一直处于高速发展的状态。
然后我觉得
那个是去年初还是前年底。
那个是前年的10月份。
前年10月份
对
应该10月
有可能10月份或者10月份。
等于差不多那时候。
从那个之后
我觉得一直都处于高速发展的状态。
我觉得coding这个场景。
有两个最大的优势。
第一个优势就是它的reward signal。
就是它的回馈的信号。
是很好定义的
因为比如说你去
比如说像software and nia这种task。
有时候经常情况就是。
我需要写一个code。
实现一个feature。
一个特征
这个特征需要的是。
某些输入会得到某些输出。
这就是一个很容易能够。
很容易能够测试的事情。
所以它的回馈信号非常清晰。
你输入和这个输出能够对。
那就说明你的实现是成功吗？
不对
那就说明不成功
但这只是一个例子。
就是在这种和写扣的相关里面。
有很多很多混账
这样是良好定义的回馈信号。
然后另一个比较大的优势是。
coding的数据。
有一个非常天然的基础。
这个基础就是github。
github上汇聚了过去几个data。
几十年很多优质的。
传讯员所写下的代码。
然后从那些代码出发。
是可以构建出非常非常多环境。
我觉得这两件事
从模型的角度上来说。
是为什么coding可以做得很好。
当然我觉得从产品上来说。
还有另外一方面的原因。
就是coding这个产品的使用需求。
其实是从不论下说是比较单一的。
它不像你去做一个。
像社交软件或者游戏。
可能每一个人都有不一样的品位。
然后你可能很难就是能够。
满足每一个人的需求。
那可能就是需要推荐算法。
但是coding这个事好。
事情在于优秀的程序员写代码。
其实风格是比较类似的。
什么风格 简洁 单净。
对 就是好的代码是。
不脏
是有一些共同的标准的。
比如说像你说的
就是这个代码简洁。
结构清楚
是于未来的开发
然后有合理的抽象。
当然还有别的很多标准。
但是我觉得好的程序。
往往是有比较共识标准的。
对这件事
所以这件事从产品上来说。
其实让coding这个产品变得更简单。
那你现在的工作百分之多少。
会用coding写代码。
它能帮你挤高工作多少倍。
你问了一个我差点会被开除的问题。
我谷歌不能用coding。
对 就是我觉得对我来说。
一个保守的估计
可能百分之九十的code是模型产生的。
但是可能就是我需要花很多时间。
去看code是不是写得合适 写得合理。
是不是真的是我想让它写的。
然后我觉得有了af辅助工具之后。
可能写code的这个事最重要的地方。
变成了你怎么去设计。
你怎么去设计你这个code的逻辑。
然后它需要和哪一个文件相关联。
然后需要做某一些事情。
然后你需要给这个模型可能给一些合理的context。
比如说这个code你可以做一个reference。
去看
真正去输出code的。
我觉得模型比人的能力强太多了。
所以说对我来说
你要实际去数有多少行code是我自己手写。
有多少行code是模型写。
我觉得保守估计模型写得超过百分之九十。
不保守的可能就是99或者100。
剩下10%是它不能写。
还是为什么你没有让它写。
保守估计90% 给我自己点面子。
我觉得它不能写
而我能写的部分已经越来越少。
过去可能是什么样的是它不能写的。
我觉得很早的时候。
可能在一年半以前。
那个时候市面上其实说白了。
就是只有cloud一家能够。
能够真的写这种软件工程code的。
那个时候模型还是能体会到很多缺陷的。
比如说它有时候可能写code的。
就只关注一个文件。
它就不会很关注那种多个文件之间的关联。
然后比如说一个class它的定义。
其实藏在很多层里后。
或者说它其实没有直接被套在这个直接的树里面。
可能这个模型就找不着。
现在我觉得这个事已经越来越少了。
真的越来越少了
作为一个researcher。
你的写程序的工作量能够是过去多少倍。
因为从写code的角度来说是比较难量化这个事。
但是如果说从比如说我做实验。
然后实现一些idea的效率了。
上来说我觉得可能比起一年。
甚至一年半以前可能都是二十甚至五十倍的加速。
对 因为现在模型真的变得可以很离谱。
你可以同时开好几个。
然后你好几个idea同时的去试。
甚至也就是说这个模型可以帮你监控一些实验。
监控一些结果之类的。
所以说还是真的是一个挺大的效率提升。
对 但是如果从个人工作时间上来说。
我觉得它好像让我工作时间变更长了。
这是为什么？
就是因为开发的速度变快了之后就越试越想试。
有越来越多的想法尤其是。
所以说感觉以前你可能存在说你有一个东西。
就是这个文件以前没见过。
你看 自己看你搞的不是很明白。
那你要去花时间去找那个人。
让你医院那个人可能就几个小时之后。
但现在就不是
你就看到这个文件 你不懂。
拿去问一下Cloud回来 咱们来。
咱们可能五秒钟就告诉你结果。
你就接着干了
所以说从工作时间上来说。
我觉得好像工作时间反而变长了。
而且工作的密度也变高了。
好 Google已经不是那个Google了什么？
不是那个可以养老的Google。
不是那个work life balance的Google。
我感觉在占AI这个领域。
没有谁可以养老
所以你现在早几晚几啊？
我一般可能早上九点钟开始。
然后晚上
到公司吗 九点
我就早上九点钟回。
可能先起来看一下邮件。
然后看一看我前天晚上实验。
然后到公司可能一般十点左右。
然后晚上如果我一个人在美国的时候。
我可能就会待到可能十点十一点这样。
然后当然我如果我家人在。
我老婆在的话
我可能就会早一点回家。
但是在家反正也是干。
所以我觉得占AI这个领域。
没有谁是在躺着的。
除非就是你已经完全对技术没有兴趣了。
对自己没有追求了。
那你躺着其实也没有人管你。
但是我觉得大家还是比较self追问。
就是还是自己想干。
你觉得其他的领域。
会出现更多这样的Cloud Code的时刻吗？
Coding之后会在哪里爆发。
你问了一个好问题。
我要是看清楚了
我可能已经出去创业了。
对 但是确实就是除了Coding之外。
我们已经能看到
就是对很多别的方向已经产生大的影响。
但只说那些方向
可能并不是一个好的这种市场上的方向。
比如说好多现在的。
做基础科学研究
就是做数学 做理论物理。
好多人其实已经就大量的还使用AI工具。
因为过去你可能
像我们做AI研究其实很像。
就是说你可能想玩一个想法。
你想跑一个数值
学部里的人又不是很会写Code的。
光学明白怎么打开这个编译器。
把Code跑起来。
可能半天已经过去了。
现在就没有这个烦恼了。
就是你现在想试
5分钟之后Code写完了。
你就可以开始试了。
对 然后甚至像Germany Deep Sync发布之后。
有很多基础科学的研究人员就把。
比如说数学推导 数学证明。
然后甚至就是去看这些不同的这种文章。
然后规纳这些事全都交给模型了。
所以说已经我觉得。
对除了Coding之外的方向产生了影响。
当然就是那些基础研究。
你可能很难就是变成一个万众主目的事情。
除非你就真的发现了一个。
以前人都没发现了很妙的理论。
比如AI产生了ISI理论这样类别的东西。
那可能会变成万众主目。
但那个时刻可能还没到完。
但是影响是已经在产生了。
我AI好神奇
它为什么首先上来。
做的都是人类觉得最难的那部分工作。
我觉得这是一个特别好的问题。
我觉得过去的在我人生的阶段里。
大家往往会觉得最智力上有挑战的工作。
反而是那些比较理性的事情。
比较客观的事情
比如说数学
比如说写代码
比如说做AI研究。
还有科学研究
对
就是越是这些事
其实AI越容易做好。
因为你一旦想清楚这些事怎么去评下。
你就知道怎么训练。
人为什么比较难呢？
你看人都是智力分配。
最高的那部分人做这些工作。
对
但是可能未来就不是这样了。
未来会怎么样
我觉得未来其实会发生的一个改变。
就是有很多AI其实没有那么容易做。
但是反而是人可能做得比较好。
比如说做产品经理。
我说实话觉得做一个好的产品经理。
是一个我现在想不明白该怎么训练AI去做的事。
这是为什么？
没有标准
没有刻度
什么叫做一个好的产品。
我其实想不太明白。
没有一个很客观的标准。
你一定是做出来之后给人用了。
你才知道它好
大家才会说它好
我觉得那个就是一个回馈信号很不明确的事。
那个我就不知道该怎么去训练AI做。
程徐元什么时候会被彻底取代吗？
会有这一天吗？
我觉得这一天会来。
但是它不会是一瞬间的来。
就不会是程徐元都还在。
过了一个晚上
第二天程徐元全被开除了。
不会是这样的
他一定会是一个见面的过程。
但是大家现在已经看到这个见面的过程。
因为有一些公司已经开始开始裁员了。
我觉得从某种意义上来说AI是一个。
从某种意义上来说它上来是一个很好的东西。
但是从某种意义上来说。
它可能也是一个很很不幸的事。
AI是一个很centralized的technology。
它会让少部分人变得更强。
但会让大部分人失去他们的独特价值。
所以说我觉得对于传统的软件工程来说。
最后变成结果可能就是。
现在千分之一的人干了过去所有人的工作。
拿着现在100倍的工资。
那你对程徐元有什么建议。
我觉得可能接收新事物。
我觉得未来程徐元可能很重要的一件事。
是怎么和AI去有效的协作。
比如说有很多事情是AI可能做的不是那么好的事。
比如说怎么去合理的设计一个事情的实际下方案。
然后怎么样设计让它可能跟这个公司未来的发展比较契合。
那这些东西可能你很难去告诉一个模型。
让它理解这些事
那这些事可能还需要人去做。
但是可能像具体的就是很具体的。
就是像过去很多程徐元做的工作。
就是你的经历告诉你实现这个下周五之前给我。
也这样的工作未来可能就不会再存在了。
那千分之一的程徐元或者什么样的程徐元。
他们的特质是什么？
首先千分之一是个叙述。
我真的不知道会是千分之一还是万分之一。
还是十万分之一
也可能是百分之一。
你不要那么悲观
我是一个著名的悲观主义者。
所以说你也不要太那时候。
然后
我觉得未来好的程徐元。
首先它肯定是
从技术上来说它一定会非常强。
因为如果你技术上的弱。
那没有什么道理
也还不能取代你
但技术强可能不会是唯一。
就不会是一个必要条件。
它可能是一个充分条件。
另一个事情我觉得会很重要的就是。
你得能够理解你的这部分工作。
在一个大的组织或者一个大的公司里。
该去怎么适配进去。
这件事情可能也是一个重要。
然后当然还有可能别的很多事情。
比如说这个人的规划能力是不是足够强。
他规划能力强的话。
他肯定可以同时把这个大的。
一个很复杂的事情拆解上很多。
相对较小的事情
然后交给不同的AI去做。
但是现在看这三种能力是重要的。
可能AI还不能完全做。
不代表6月之后不能。
可能6月之后你过来问我。
我发现最后一个是AI已经能干了。
那就只剩两个事
再过这个月可能剩下两个也能干了。
那可能我就回答就会变得更悲观。
所以说没有人能预计6月之后发生什么？
我只能说从现在的观点来说。
刚过去的那个春节。
很多人关注另外一件事情是Cdance。
Cdance会让Google交流吗？
我觉得其实有可能有。
但是这个交流的情绪目前还没有传导到我这。
可能让Google Demine的负责多么太深层的团队。
会有一些压力
但是如果你要问我的话。
我觉得我可能不觉得他们有什么可焦虑的。
就是我觉得并没有体现出什么犯事上的改变。
更多的是我觉得自己在。
不管是这个产品的效果。
还是可能在数据上之类的。
这些细节会做得非常好。
我觉得确实是
字节过去在多么太深层一直以来都有比较强的优势。
但是我觉得
知道我跟人没有体会到它是一个犯事上的变化。
那可能就不足以说让大家非常的焦虑。
但是肯定是有压力。
Cdance它的产品能力来自于模型能力还是产品能力。
我没在自己也干过。
所以我也不知道具体的细节。
但是你要让我猜
我觉得可能模型还是占大头的。
模型能力的好来自于什么？
来自于数据
因为算吧？
可能没有本质创新。
我觉得算法
首先就是因为刚才多么太属于咱们说的就是。
科学问题
多么太的深层属于科学问题。
对多么太深层还属于一个比较科学问题。
所以说多么太理解解决了吗？
比生成肯定是要有更系统的理解。
但是比起Tax2Kin来说。
肯定还是没有那么的。
那范图还没有那么固定。
对
我觉得生成肯定可能就是。
因为它是一个还没有。
范图还没有固定的事。
可能每家用的技术都会有一些大了。
或者小的区别
然后现在更多的只是能看到说。
效果上来说
可能字节和Google Dmg。
属于在效果上来说做的比较好。
所以它可能也是来自于。
细节做的更好
对
你如果要让我猜
我会猜数据
数据
你要让我猜我会猜数据。
但是
我也没在字节干过。
所以也是我硬猜的。
你怎么看
从Google去字节的我永恒呀？
我喝得很能
评价有灰
我觉得
我当过去没有和永恒一起工作过。
所以我其实真的不是很能。
给什么很好的评价。
很客观的评价
但是我觉得我去了。
JAMLINE之后。
看到的更多的是永恒好的一面。
我觉得它是我
通过偷偷去看它以前交过的代瓦。
以及它代过的项目。
我的感觉是
它是我见到的少数。
层级非常高
然后人也很 senior。
但是还有很强的技术能力。
我觉得是非常少见。
所以我觉得
我觉得我可能是
还没到能够评价永恒的水平。
但是要让问我说的话。
我觉得永恒是非常强的。
你说站在2016年的QE的拍一张快照。
你觉得中美的模型能力。
差距是在放大还是缩小。
差多远
我觉得
如果现在放映中快照。
去看过去一年的发展趋势。
或者过去一年半的发展趋势。
显然中美之间的概谱是越边越小。
但是最后这个概谱会不会完全。
迷和甚至中国超过去。
那我觉得是一个不清楚的问题。
我觉得对中国的AI的研究员。
来说
研究机构来说也是一个机会。
然后
我觉得一个很真实的事。
就是中国确实在实际的算力资源上来说。
是占很大劣势
但是这个很大的劣势。
可能反而逼出了一些有趣的事。
比如说中国的卫星公司。
其实对discordation就真有别人很在好。
对
最近大瑞不是点名了三家公司真留他。
我觉得其实可能是一个。
真留这个事存在是一个新招不宣的事实。
但是我觉得真留他也有不同的方式。
就是也有硬征和聪明的争。
两种不一样的选择。
你要硬征
硬征就是最绝对的灾难例子。
就是我从cloud里面取出一堆他生成的token。
然后强行在上面做训练。
这个如果干这样的事。
我就觉得
所言商业上也不是很道德。
然后
治理上来说也比较愚蠢。
因为干这个事的公司。
其实本质上来说他体现出来的一件事。
就是他其实都不知道自己想干嘛？
他能干这唯一件事就是超别。
然后让自己的模型数据上能看好看一点。
但本来他就说明他自己都不知道该干嘛？
这是硬征
但是其实真留也有一些很有趣的科学问题。
就是比如说我是不是。
有种可能就随便举个例子。
就是有没有可能是我生成我自己生成数据的这个链条当中用到了别的模型作为辅助。
或者说我自己模型生成的答案。
用别的模型作为他的评价者。
这个其实是一个我觉得。
商业上来说比较灰色的地带。
但是从技术上来说其实很有意思。
因为你想其实
从某种意义上来说。
可能中国的实验室成为了做multiagent训练的先驱。
而且是真正的multiagent。
因为它是个从不同家的模型里。
用这种比较聪明的方案。
把它们融会到一个训练系统里的话。
每家模型它可能是分布很不一样。
它的语言的分布很不一样。
这个是真正的multiagent。
它可能比起比如说我用好几个咱们来一块做。
是一个技术上更有趣的事。
所以说我觉得
对我来说聪明的真。
我不知道这个商业上最后会不会变成一个很明确错。
或者很明确对的事。
但是技术上其实很有意思。
你这两种真分明说的是谁。
能不能后期把名字逼掉。
我首先没有在中国的live干过。
所以我不知道确切的事实。
但是我的感觉就是。
应该是应征了
然后可能曾经应征过。
但是后来可能慢慢也在努力向软针的方向转化。
我觉得比较明显可能挣留的比较少的是自己。
我觉得自己是我感觉到这个模型还是比较特点。
特点体现在哪里
比如说这个模型你说它有多聪明呢？
我觉得豆包是肯定没有展版奶和callow的聪明的。
但是首先比如说豆包的语音生成非常非常强。
这个很难吗在技术上。
确实豆包是做得最好的。
因为我发现我生活上的问题我只想问豆包用得很快。
但其他模型为什么不优化这个产品功能呢？
我觉得还是跟它的应用群体有关系。
在美国我觉得大家的这个想法。
更专注于怎么能够提高工作效率。
你生活没有一些困惑吗？
我生活中有
首先我个人确实是一个生活上比较无聊的人。
所以我生活中没有很多有趣的困惑可以去问豆包。
我生活中更多的困惑都是技术上的困惑。
问展版奶这种聪明的模型就是最好的。
对我没有什么半夜去打豆包情感电台的需求。
不只是情感就是很多。
比如说你做饭你可能会遇到一个什么问题。
你可能其实需要一个需要有人告诉你。
但是你又没有不知道没有这样的人。
那些我觉得可能更多是数据上的问题。
然后可能更多指说美国的公司现在主要的。
主要的优先级是在。
智能或者工作效率上。
未来有天会不会变成这些日常的事情。
我觉得是有可能的。
事实情况是你如果去问这种日常话题。
其实你能发现展版奶每代。
一代到另外一代会做的也越来越好。
其实我身边很多朋友包括我自己以前也是。
就是我以前在那套认识我可能写扣子会去问客老我的。
但我可能日常查个什么东西我就会去问展版奶。
你用我豆包没有
我其实只用过一两次。
我发现你们都不怎么用。
是不是有比试链
有智力的比试链
没有不至于
我觉得首先就是
就跟在中国人试图用美国的模型会有一些复杂的事。
我在美国用中国的模型其实也是挺复杂的。
第二就是也没这个动机。
尤其我觉得我可能生活中。
工作是工作
休闲的时候就是找不一样的工作。
对我来说我的最好伙伴就是客老的和展版奶。
但是可能对别人来说并不是这样。
所以可能也只是我个人的问题。
我自己用豆包的那一两次。
是因为有人给我展示豆包手机。
你怎么看豆包手机。
我觉得是一个很好的想法。
我个人觉得效果上来说其实做的也不错。
当然我不知道的是。
技术上来说它的优化做的有多好。
我觉得它实现一些任务的实施。
从效果上来说是没什么问题。
但我不知道它会有多大消耗。
如果这个消耗非常大。
那可能是一个技术上需要解决的问题。
因为你并不希望什么让你的模型去给你订了一张高铁票。
结果花的钱比高铁票还贵。
这个肯定是一个不可以接受的事。
对 所以说
可能技术上来说
我个人不清楚它有多成熟。
然后我觉得
常常说对大家来说还是一个挺。
不能说惊讶
但是让大家觉得挺兴奋的事。
然后我觉得可能苹果以前也想干这样的事。
其实苹果可能自家的模型一直不太行。
苹果好像不是在于它的AI战略。
现在
我觉得苹果一定是在于AI战略的。
因为曾经Siri手机助手。
是苹果发布会里一个非常非常重要的闪光点。
但是自己的模型没赶上趟。
现在可能要通过和咱们来合作。
来试图做这样的事。
至于现在它是不是重视。
首先我也不知道
你要让我猜我肯定觉得是重视。
但你要让我解释它为什么从外界来看没那么重视。
我的唯一猜测就是。
如果你外界来看就显得很重视。
还做不成那就显得很蠢。
晚尊
对
好不在意
我们说一下豆磅的模型。
你刚才说豆磅的模型比较有特色。
你们具体一点
一个是要语音做的很好。
这是第一点
我觉得语音做的很好。
是我能感觉到最有特色的事。
就是我觉得语音这个效果。
可能是客气的说可能是前世纪最好的之一。
不客气的说我觉得就是前世纪最好的。
这很难吗？
我自己没做到那个例不过。
所以我也不知道是不是难。
但是我觉得可能是一个很费功夫的事。
不管从数据上还是各种优化上来说。
它是个产品的事还是个模型的事。
它一定会是模型的事。
它有可能也包含一些产品的部分。
但一定是一个模型的事。
然后我觉得这是一方面。
然后另一方面
另一方面我自己感受就不多了。
因为我其实用的机会没那么多。
那可能就是更多的是来自于亲朋好友的反馈。
也就是说这个多巴掌模型就是。
方子talk就是聊起来很有气。
但我觉得那个更多的是一些主观的反馈。
我觉得它的那个
一个是语音
然后一个是它身上的很快。
也是一个很重要的。
因为我很多模型它都在给你展示思维链。
但是我就说那个生活上的所是。
我不想看它的思维链。
对这个事我觉得技术上并不难。
只是可能大家目前还没有花更多时间在这个上面。
然后事实情况是
如果你去尝试ZenMai 3.1和ZenMai 3的话。
你会发现ZenMai 3.1在完成的。
我按一个问题的时候。
已经会比以前快很多。
然后废话少很多了。
所以说我觉得这个不是一个。
在我看来不是一个技术上的难点。
它更多只是什么时候去重视去做这个事。
我觉得可能就是现在。
既然美国的这几家。
还都处于在努力把智能的上线往前不断推进。
二字节呢？
当然它也肯定是在推进上线的。
但是我觉得它可能就是在用户的用法上也做得很不错。
最近还有一个话题。
就是中国的机器人红火在春晚上。
我不知道你对这个有没有什么观察。
看过一些表演
也在亚马逊上搜过一些价格。
确实很惊讶
它居然这么便宜
买了吗？
没买
我买了也没什么用。
但是确实我以前会。
我不知道我以前脑海里觉得这种人性机器人。
然后当然就软件层面其实没什么？
但主要是硬件
我觉得硬件想做的这么成熟。
可能怎么也得是个什么大几百万美金啊？
这样的
好像我去看了一下价格比这要便宜很多。
我觉得这还是体现出中国在硬件。
产业链上还是很有优势。
但是我并不知道它作为一个。
它作为一个机器人硬件来说。
我觉得确实是非常非常强。
然后从软件上来说。
没太看明白
我觉得机器人的模型。
也是一个目前非共识比较大的事情。
怎么说
就是说它
我觉得机器人的模型可能更多的处于。
Future Engineering的时代。
就是你有一个给定的环境。
给定的场景
你去优化这个场景。
大家是知道怎么做的。
但是做2L嘛？
做强化学习
做强化学习构建合适的虚拟环境。
还是虚拟的这种数据。
然后你去做训练
是可以提高的
但是它没有很强的泛化性。
我觉得这个是
就是有没有泛化性。
其实是很多AI方向它的一个分水里。
就是一个确定的场景。
一个很单一的场景。
能不能做好
这个事不是最近这几年才解决的。
十几年前就能干
就是像语言也是
语言在这个基于传双模式。
这种类似架构之前的时代里。
并不是说完全做不了。
那时候你也可以训练。
也很强谋模型去做翻译。
你也可以训练
也很强谋模型去做语言分析。
但是你不能做的事。
是我可以水平的提高所有的能力。
这个我觉得是一个分水里。
然后我觉得
蓝硅之貌在
在传双模和GBT之后。
跨过了那样一个阶段。
跨过了一个
就是可以水平的提高所有的能力。
然后你可能在一个点上来训练。
它会把这样能力出向的方向。
到所有相关的事情上。
但是机械人我觉得没当这个阶段。
更多的还是在那个阶段之前。
就是我有一个单一的场景。
单一的事情
然后我能够为这个事情去做优化。
所以你怎么看硅谷的这些机器人团队。
还包括GEM的内部也有很多机器人的人。
你会怎么看那个方向。
有点这算什么？
只是你们的子方向还是你们的。
平行方向还是什么？
我觉得过去是一个挺平行的方向。
但是现在机器人
我觉得大家也在尝试。
就是能不能利用语言模型。
作为一个基底模型。
然后在那个上面去训练。
这种类似比如像VLA这种类似的。
特别是多文态模型。
对
然后
所以现在来说
就是变成了和语言模型。
这个这条线比较相关的一条线。
然后我觉得
我个人的感觉是
他们未来会变得很重要。
但是目前还没有找到自己的路。
但是他们做的事真的很有意思。
我非常推荐大家去看看机器人的实验室。
比做了语言模型的实验室要有趣的多。
做了语言模型的实验室。
感觉就是正常的办公室。
但机器人
他们是真的就是会有人去。
操控这个机器人采集各种数据。
然后去看这个机器人在什么？
在货架里去取不原样的货品之类。
干什么的事情
最后是很有意思的一件事。
你吃的是哪家
我在GEMMA自己的实验室。
就是那个谷歌丁曼的自己的实验室。
去看过
然后还有那个Dana。
我一起看过
他们是个叠衣服的机器人。
对
他们就是可能场景更单一一点。
就是我叠衣服是叠机器人。
可能做一些别的谈。
就比如说倒水之类的。
你直观感觉机器人进展。
相当于带原模型的一年。
还没有到GPT1的时刻。
对不对
一定没到
我觉得一定是没到。
对
相当于大家
还没有想明白怎么去skill up。
我觉得对我来说
不管机器人还是多么太生成。
都没到这个点
那接下来进入今天的主题。
我们还是对你非常的感兴趣。
然后聊一聊
你是怎么从一个学务里的人。
进入AI的世界的。
你从小在哪长大
你是怎么长大的
我出生在宁夏
然后一个很小很小的城市。
叫大湖口
你看你这困惑的表情。
已经说明了这个城市有多小。
这个城市过去的存在是因为一个煤矿。
对 因为实在是你一个煤矿。
然后有了这样一个城市。
所以我一在那出生。
但是我小学的时候。
跟我父母一块去到上海。
然后所以我小学的后半段。
和初中高中是在上海。
然后我上本科就去了北京。
就是刚才说的那些。
本科在北京
然后博士在美国
你从小都成绩很好是吗？
你是物理竞赛宝宋。
然后在清华和斯坦夫读的是理论物理。
对 我不是物理竞赛宝宋的。
我觉得我想说挺菜的。
首先我读的初中和小学都是无名之辈。
我觉得我当时读的初中好像。
就是竞赛
不是一个你该考虑的事。
就处于这样一种这么一个初中理。
那个叫上南中学东校。
又是一个大家听了很困惑。
一脸一头霧水的学校。
既然都说到这人家小学是哪个小学。
小学叫啥来着
我的Connect Manager们能力太强了。
我已经不记得叫什么歧视。
可以
然后就是那个初中。
就是一个班里面一个小环境。
还是有一些想好好感受的同学的。
但是总体来说
那个初中我觉得是比较躺平的状态。
然后我觉得就是可能还学习还可以。
当时的状态就是上海高中有所谓的。
那时候有所谓的私校。
就是什么上海中学。
然后华尔交达和负担的附属中学。
然后当时的状态就是能上这四个学校。
但上不了这个四个学校里最好的班。
但是我当时特别想搞竞赛。
因为以前都没搞过竞赛。
你初中还是搞竞赛。
我初中没搞
我初中没搞过竞赛。
你没搞过竞赛为什么想搞竞赛。
因为没搞过所以想搞。
怎么植入了这概念。
我这个人的个性就是。
总是爱干一些自己不太会的事。
对
然后当时没搞过竞赛。
但是知道有这么回事。
所以觉得
一不交易
不是一不交易
就是上大学之前得干一把。
所以但是成绩也没好到那个份儿上。
所以去私校
最好的那四个学校是进不了搞竞赛那个班的。
但是我当时就发现有一个稍微差点的学校。
那个学校就是革职中学。
稍微差一点的学校。
但是那个学校有一个竞赛班。
然后我感觉这个
这个竞赛班按照现在的话说就是。
Underdog。
厉害
用当时的话说
我感觉就是光脚的不怕穿鞋的。
我觉得
可以一搞
所以就
其实当时那个
那时候就是
那时候上海还有就是所谓的退休生的指路。
就是你可以在考试前就去和某一学校签约。
然后你就提前一下。
预订一个学校的名额。
然后就直接去
去他们那儿
然后就很自然去了。
然后去搞了竞赛
搞中
对
然后
所以你其实是在上海私校的普通班里面。
和这个革制中学的竞赛班里面。
义务反顾的选了革制中学的竞赛班。
当然我也不能
我不能说我做选择的时候。
这个上了最好的四个高中是那么？
板上定阶这些事
虽然后来的分确实够了。
但是那时候
你那时候还没有中考。
那时候还没有中考。
对
但是当时就觉得
就算能上
我也应该去一个
Underdog地方赌一把。
为什么？
因为想干这个事
你想干竞赛的目的是什么？
我觉得当时最主要的事。
是想体验
我觉得没干过
一定要搞去干一下。
为什么一定要干一下。
这个
第一就是觉得他确实难。
就是确实
就有一种对男的新闻感。
对
就是确实
至少当时没搞的时候。
大家给我的印象就是感觉这个事。
比你不搞竞赛学的那些东西。
要有挑战性的多了。
你觉得干这个事人确实强。
不干
你也就是这个平庸石头里最光滑的那一个。
所以我当然觉得要干。
所以就去干
当然干了之后
也实际上带了一些好处。
我后来回想起来
如果当时没去搞竞赛。
可能就进不了新华了。
你是有加分还是什么？
当时其实
那个竞赛的保送生制度已经比较锐减了。
就只有进国家集训队才能保送。
我那高中
反正我觉得我当时没进国家集训队这个水平的。
所以就别说了
但是我在考高三竞赛之前。
阴差阳错的去清华叹尼尔里的夏令营。
然后阴差阳错的在夏令营的。
最后一天听说了
他们在搞自招生
但是主要是面向北京的学生。
我就疯狂给招生办的老师发短信。
说我要跟他们一块考。
他答应了
然后他就答应了我们去考。
你们还是你
答应了我们高中一块去的那几个人去考。
上海去夏令营的那几个高中同学去考。
你有什么理由说服他你来发短信。
我已经忘了一个短信具体怎么说了。
但这个短信大概说的意思就是。
你给北京的同学考为什么不给上海的考。
大家难道不许
理直气壮
你当时觉得他们开后门是吗？
我也不是觉得他们开后门。
就是觉得人家有这个机会凭什么不给我们。
大家都在一条线上竞争。
就你们当时同学
然后所以就发了这个信息。
然后人家就真让我们去考了。
几个人
我去不小心了
可能有上海去那个考上里。
可能有七八个人的样子。
是你发那个短信
可能别的高中有别的学业发。
但我们高中是我发的。
就是都是上海高中去北京。
参加夏令营的同学。
然后就让我们去考。
然后就签了
这么好说话
对
所以我从那件事表达的人生最重要的道理。
就是
胆子有大
你不争取是永远得不到的。
争取了也有可能得不到。
但不争取就绝对得不到。
你当时发那个短信的时候忐忑吗？
你当时还高中
我已经不记得了
当然觉得自己这是个很大胆的事吗？
还是还好
我当时满脑想的都是。
现在就得争取
再不争取 明天就争取不到。
就当天就发了
就是我在听说的那天就赶紧去疯狂发短信。
疯狂发给谁发
发给招数办的清华招数办的老师。
就发给了一个人还是多个人。
不记得了 应该是一个老师。
他很快回了吗？
我觉得清华
就算Yes了
我不知道他们自己有没有讨论了。
但是反正最后是说了是。
同一
那就一起考试了
对
所以我为什么？
我感觉我一直对清华还是挺有感情的。
就我感觉这个学校。
是
是愿意给大家提供机会。
给大家提供评论机会的。
你那个考试考怎么样。
我当时出来的时候觉得。
考挺崩的
因为有半档题没做出来。
但是我后来发现别人没做出来更多。
就果然就着了
你们那一波上海同学。
进了几个
好像两个
最后只要是减分还是什么？
是降到一本线
降到一本线
对
然后你高考考好吗？
后来高考
果然没考到清华的分。
但是就是除了清北之外的学校都能上。
所以为什么？
网上都写你是保送的。
我觉得就是大家
不在那个没在那几年上过学的人。
很难理解进入那几年到底发生了什么？
因为在我的两届之前。
还是拿了省一等奖就能保送的。
拿了省一等奖就能保送。
就能保送的
你们那时候呢？
我们那时候就是
拿了省一等奖进了省队。
然后再代表省队去考国家的比赛。
然后进了国家急性队才能保送。
我是进了省队去考了国家的比赛。
但我没考进国家急性队。
对
所以说我那届我是没有保送生病。
免恶的
你搞进再搞了好吗？
我觉得挺菜的
就是难道不是没有干到最好就是很菜吗？
然后显然没有干到最好。
所以就是很菜
你家里人对你搞进赛这个事情是什么态度。
我觉得我爸妈最好的一点。
就是他们不太管我。
他们可能曾经也是都管过我。
后来发现管不住
怎么管不住
就是我也不听他们的。
我觉得
可能
大多数中国家庭都是孩子和父母商量。
已经算是很好的了。
我一般都是通知
通知了啥
通知哦
我去自主招生了
然后包括中高考田志愿也是。
我爸妈甚至可能都没见过我之前。
但
他们比较服我是吗？
他们
我觉得就是
当你没有办法理解别人在干什么的时候。
别人这是我画脚就是最好的。
我觉得我爸妈这个道理懂得很好。
那你是表判定是吗？
我觉得我是比较
因为我觉得我个性是我很care。
我想做的事
如果这件事是我自己想明白了要去做。
你就别拦我
然后我也一定会尽最大能力做到最好。
但如果这个事我不想干。
比我干也没用
我也不会干
你的胜负欲强吗？
挺强
对但我觉得
我更多的是在跟自己跟自己较劲。
不是不太愿意和别人较劲。
当然就是如果还问。
就是如果正好是
我觉得这事很重要。
你也觉得这事很重要。
那我肯定是要干得比你好。
好那你到了清华就更省了。
去学了量子物理为啥。
对我当时做那个您看理论。
然后
为什么选这个专业。
阴差阳错
现在回过头来说
当然能编造出一些。
听起来很合理的理由。
但是摸着良心回到当初。
我觉得就是阴差阳错。
就是当时我们在计客班。
然后计客班有一个非常好的传统。
就是首先计客班
他虽然在物理系
但他不限制学生干什么？
所以计客班实际上。
三分之二的学生都不会做物理。
然后对于那种
你为什么会进这个班。
当时清华的物理系全都是计客班。
现在可能不是
反正当时是
然后他另外一个好的传统。
是他鼓励学生在实践中学习。
所以他鼓励学生
尽早的去进到科研人的实验室里去了。
然后去和在科研中学习。
然后我当然想很想做理论。
然后
这就觉得这个难吗？
是吧？
感觉就是你的难有一种着迷。
可能也是一种病
之后可以再讲讲
这个病带来的不良后果是。
好
对
然后然后那个对
然后我想搞理论
然后当时计客班
或者我们叫学堂班。
有一个更小一点班。
然后那个老师就推荐说。
高等研究院是个很好的地方。
清华高等研究院
就是杨德宁先生创立的研究院。
是个很好的地方
完完我就去那找老师。
然后
正好有一个
那时候还很年轻的老师叫。
叫王忠是我本科的老师。
那时候他也没几个学生。
然后
我俩就聊
我当然啥也不懂
但他还是挺贪心
还给我了
给了我一些这个paper。
让我去读
然后读过我就跟他讨论。
后来又发现
音音态理论
尤其当时做的那个方案。
就是跟透布局员体。
然后
这些这些比较相关的方向。
其实是一个
很适合本科生上手的方向。
就是他需要的背景知识不太多。
他只需要你可能懂最最基本的。
就是你得会量子力学。
会统计力学
会顾虚物理
也就是
其实非常非常容易学的基础。
是基础
这是
但是他可能很考验。
你对这些知识理解的深度。
所以对本科生来说。
其实是一个特别特别好的方向。
就是你能够很快的上手。
去做一些实际的项目。
然后我们就一块做了一些工作。
其中有可能在开放量子梯系里面的那个工作。
现在看来还是一个挺重要的工作。
然后
从某种意义上来说。
我觉得
现在回头来看
做那个工作
做那段时间的科研。
其实和现在做的特别特别像。
就是他更多的是
你有一个想法
你有一个理解
然后你可以
在那个阶段
就是你可以做一个数值的实验。
去验证你这个想法和理解是不是对的。
你发现
AI其实也是这样。
AI是你有一个想法。
你有一个理解
你去设计一些实验。
验证你的理解是不是对的。
然后你设计一些
模型上的训练的这个处理。
来把你的想法实施出来。
对
虽然其实这两个是很像。
能不能讲讲你这个非恶密系统的研究。
可以讲
我尽量说人话
但是也有可能
实际上说了一个诡话。
所以要是不想听的人。
可以跳过
画一下进击条
画一下净子
当时可以在净子前。
然后设置两个戳
对
然后对非恶密系统是这样。
就是说
量子力学一个最基本的假设。
是一个孤立系统
他的演化被妖症养化所描述。
妖症养化是个诡话。
对不起
妖症养化的意思
就是它是一个现行的过程。
然后这个现行过程。
它可以被一个算子。
叫做哈密敦的量来描述。
哈密敦的量从某种意义上来说。
它有点像这个体系的能量。
但不完全是
就是有点类似于
所以它决定了这个体系。
随着时间的演化
然后如果是一个孤立系统的话。
这个哈密敦的量会是一个恶密的矩阵。
恶密的矩阵就是你转制一下。
然后做一下功额
它和原来是一样
但是真实的系统
决大多数都不是孤立系统。
例如说你我作为人。
肯定要和外界有信息交互。
有物质的交互
材料也不一样
就是你一块材料放在那。
除非你抽特别的被遮空的。
你总得和趁力有交互。
你得和外界环境有交换。
所以真实的体系
决大多数时候都不是孤立系统。
然后孤立系统
它就不会被一个妖症的过程去描述。
然后它所对应的哈密敦的量。
也不会是一个恶密的哈密敦的量。
就是这个非恶密这个死的来源。
它本质上是为了研究开放量子系统。
就和外界有交换的量子系统。
它的行为
然后当时发现一个很困惑的事。
是我们一开始
是试图研究开放量子系统里的。
一些透泼现象
然后就发现
手算出来的理论的结果。
核数值子火也对不上。
然后更确定的说
就是手算结果
是假设了这个体系。
是一个周期的编辑条件。
比如说它在一个环上。
或者在一个轮胎的表面上。
然后数值的话
就会因为和实际的情况比较类似。
会算一个开放边界的。
就是一个方块
这个材料上的行为。
就发现这两个结果死火也对不上。
然后就试图理解这个事。
后来就发现
大家过去用来描述恶密系统的一个。
一个基本的范世
就是所谓的布罗赫波。
就假设物体的本成态。
都是一些波的线性组合。
所谓一些政权一线波。
这种波的线性组合。
这个假设
这个假设其实在
非热密系统里面会break down。
就是会变成错的
实际情况就是
后来我们就发现在非热密系统里。
其实它的能量的本状态。
都会有可能会聚集到。
这个体系的一边边去。
对
然后我们就系统的建立了。
这套描述的方法
然后就是建立一套体系。
去描述一个开放边界的。
非热密系统
它的本状态该怎么去描述。
竟然而描述它的一些随时间。
演化和一些动力学。
所以这个是当时这份工作。
然后后来就有很多。
因为它其实是一个。
一个范世上的更新。
所以后来就有很多。
follow up的工作。
但是后来其实我换方向了。
所以就没有太在这个方向。
继续做了
你为什么不严任它做。
很难抓住一次范世的变化。
是不是
是的
这就是人性的弱点。
就是我感觉我总爱挑战一些。
自己不会的事
尤其当时就
我不知道我当时的感觉是。
在那个方向
可能那个工作从再过几年回头来看。
就会是这个方案最重要的工作。
后面你再去做一些工作。
可能确实会让你更有名。
获得更多的引诱
写更多好的机开的文章。
找了一个好的较值。
但是感觉
作为一个科学生来说。
就没那么令人激动了。
所以我当时就想换个东西做。
换一个自己不太会的东西做。
然后所以就读博士的时候。
就换了一个方向去做高能理论。
高能理论
对 高能理论物理。
所以你本科和博士也是不一样的。
也是不一样的
还不是从物理跳到AI。
其实你本科和博士看起来都是物理。
其实方向也已经发生了很大的变化。
对 是两个
几乎没有任何联系的方向。
你这个很神奇
还包括你选竞赛
去那个格制中学也很神奇。
对
这是你的什么人性。
我觉得就是
说难听了就是爱折磨自己。
说好听的是挑战自己。
被折磨开心吗？
我觉得如果
为了被折磨而被折磨。
那这个人就是有心理疾病。
但是如果一个人是为了学习更多的东西。
丰富自己的经历和能力。
而被折磨
我觉得是值得的
你本科那个老师
王忠老师也是个underdog 是吧？
算吗？
不算
人家做的挺好的
是不是可以这样出来。
在那个时候
你刚刚来说还是很年轻吗？
没有
他很年轻
但是他
我对他的印象一直都是。
他是一个很soft的人。
就是很能看问题
试图理解问题理解很清楚的人。
确实可能不像很多老师那样。
是很有名气在社会上。
或者很光彩多目
只要那时候不是
现在已经很有名气了。
那时候还没有那么有名气。
但是我觉得从能力上来说。
我觉得他是很强的。
然后其实他一开始是。
他读博社的时候
是和那个首承老师。
张首承老师学习
所以说能被首承老师挑战的人。
基本都不会太差
他对于你博社换方向。
说过什么吗？
没说过什么？
我觉得他是一个
不爱干涉别人的人。
我不知道他内心是怎么想的。
但是我觉得
他是一个不爱干涉别人的人。
量子物理整个是一个什么样的世界观。
他跟
我觉得最大的区别就是。
我觉得和景点物理。
有很多不一样的地方。
但是我觉得他们俩是一个对应的感觉。
是吧？
景点物理和量子物理。
他们俩是一个在不同能量和时间。
或者空间尺度下的理论。
就是说本质上我们这世界都是量子的。
当然我们现在也不知道比更小的。
吃不吃饱会什么？
对吧？
就更像吃饱有很多不一样的想法。
比如说旋转是一个想法。
然后可能其他想法。
就是全量自己也是个想法之类的。
但那些都没有办法验证。
被验证的小尺度上的有效理论。
就是量子物理
最小的尺寸
对
就是被实验上能够验证的。
最小尺寸的有效理论就是量子。
当然这里面包括量子力学和量子炒的。
然后今年物理是当你所看的这个空间尺度。
和比较大的时候
这个量子物理会慢慢退化成了今年物理。
所以说它更多的是在不同尺度下的。
不同的有效理论
对
这个事其实在物理上是一个很深刻的想法。
就是所谓的重重化群。
重重化群说的事就是说。
在描述一个体系的理论。
在不同的能量尺度下。
可能看起来是完全不一样。
对
然后哪怕他们可能从根源上来说。
都是一个大一同旅乐。
当然现在没有什么真正的大一同旅乐。
如果存在的话
他们哪怕在根源上同一个根。
但是他们在不同尺度上。
可能看起来也是完全不一样。
然后所以经典物理和量子物理。
更多是两个不同尺度下的描述。
讲到量子物理有几个词好像是相关的。
比如说蝴蝶效应
比如说量子纠缠
能不能讲讲这些
我觉得这个可能是大家能听得懂的。
然后我也不懂物理。
大家不要骂我
我也不懂量子物理。
对
我觉得量子纠缠确实是一个。
大家比较二叔能详的量子物理。
比较独特的事情
然后就是很简单的。
就是说我有两个例子。
比如说它属于一个纠缠态。
然后我可能他们实际上相隔很远。
但实际上我可能对其中一个做一些测量。
或者围绕
它也会影响到另外一个的状态。
这个是真实存在的。
对
真实存在的
什么样的会有量子纠缠。
什么样两个物体
有很多
就是有很多实际的情况。
就是实际上当你足够看得足够。
足够细
足够足够微观的时候。
绝大多数的例子可能都处于纠缠态。
但是实际上来说
你可以比如说制造一个自选。
和另外一个自选
你先把它俩靠在一块。
然后把它探索到一个纠缠态上。
然后你可以把其中一个拉得很远。
它俩就成为一个距离很远的纠缠态。
然后甚至好像
我记得几年以前
还有人专门去做一个细菌和一个什么东西。
然后置备在一个量子纠缠态里。
什么叫置配在一个量子纠缠态里。
这个是可以人为操作的。
这是一个可以人为操作的时候。
为什么？
怎么操作
一般来说就是通过一些。
测量和演化算浮的作用。
能够把它置备到这个状态上。
但是这里面
难的其实是实际上怎么实现这个过程。
就是你可以想象
就是说你做一些量子测量和一些。
所谓的量子门的操作。
其实是比较难的
因为又回到刚才的问题。
就是每一个体系它其实都不是孤立的。
你可能这两个自选。
你觉得我这么置备一下。
他觉得到纠缠态了吗？
那我再把它拉开不就完了。
但是实际的问题是这两个粒子。
其实活在我们这个世界里。
会不断有别的粒子状态一下。
或者外面的这两个绕动态一下。
他一下就状态就没有。
所以难的是怎么具体实现上去实施这个过程。
对
然后纠缠的另外一个粒子。
可能更好说明一下。
我其实应该提那个粒子。
就是确定个猫
确定个猫
对
那就是一个更好说的像粒子。
就说它的状态其实是。
叠加了某一个放射源。
发出粒子和猫死了。
这是一个状态
另外状态是放射源没有发出粒子。
猫或者这两个东西的叠加状态。
其实比如说你去测量一下放射源。
发现放射源放出粒子。
你就状猫死了
不管是猫还是放射源离多远。
对
其实这是纠缠
但是蝴蝶效应是另外一个的事。
然后蝴蝶效应就是。
蝴蝶效应就是耳熟能相的部分。
其实反而是经典物理。
其实大家经典物理听。
听到的蝴蝶效应就是那个。
著名粒子就是什么？
可能南美洲一个蝴蝶铺愣一下翅膀。
半个月之后
我什么北美洲挂了一个台风。
但是它从更数学的表述来说。
它就是说在时间起始的时候。
你如果做一个很小的扰动。
然后去测量这个扰动。
产生的影响在未来有多大。
你会发现这个扰动的变化。
是指数级变大的
对
这是它数学上对经典蝴蝶效应的一个描述。
但是之前大家比较费解的一件事。
就是这个事情在粒子体系里。
怎么可能存在
原来体系刚刚说的。
就孤立粒子体系是一个腰正眼。
确实是一个很现行的过程。
所以说从某种意义上来说。
就是你如果一个状态。
就是一个识量
和另外一识量开始的时候。
佳角不太大
那经过一些演化之后。
这个佳角应该不会变。
然后所以怎么会存在这种。
就是初始状态变得离得很差别。
很小
在未来就变得就是指数级变大了。
好像在粒子力学上。
看是不太可能实现的事。
但刚刚又说
其实我们的世界是在微观是量子。
然后在红光就变成精链了。
但它俩一脉相承
怎么可能这有根本没有。
这是大家都理解的事。
当然后来大家就有一些更好的理解。
就是说其实你讨论这个粒子里面。
红光相远时候
不应该讨论两个态之间的变化。
而是应该讨论一些所谓的。
local or observable。
就是局域的观测量的变化。
那个其实是对应了经典物理的。
你的看到的那些变化。
那你读了四年的粒子物理以后。
你当时在想什么？
你觉得物理对你的帮助是什么？
在你大肆要毕业的时候。
我觉得本科期间读物理最大的帮助就是。
第一 想问题要想清楚。
就是读书不在于读的多而在于读的深。
你读的多不代表你能够发现新的东西。
但如果你对一件事有和别人不一样的见解。
那个才是对这个社会来说更有价值的事。
这一件 然后另外一件事就是别太相信理论。
别太相信纯理论
因为
得出了这个结论
因为当时那个事发现的主要原因。
还是因为能做数值。
就是一开始是因为数值和理论对不上。
才仔细地研究那个问题。
然后发现了这个事。
那你博士为什么去读了高能物理。
也是一个理论
就回到了刚才这个话题。
就是总爱挑战很难的事。
有时候也是会带来一些不好的结果的。
什么不好的结果
比如我就感觉
我觉得我这个博士就是对我自己来说。
学到了很多东西
成长很大
但是与这个世界来说。
没有产生有没有贡献。
就是高能理论这方案就是足够难。
非常非常难
然后
但它不好的事情在于。
它其实不是特别可以验证。
没有什么客观的评价标准。
因为高能理论已经发展到了。
就是实验完全追不上的这个阶段。
实验完全追不上
你在理论讨论的那些。
不管是能量尺度
还是这种微观的尺度。
所以说
它是怎么进步的
它的进步依赖于什么？
如果不是实验
一个进步的来源
是来自于数学上的自下性。
比如说你提出一个框架。
来描述这些事情
但你能和现有的
已经被验证的
更低能标下的理论。
想自洽
就比如说你研究闲论。
那可能自然大家问题就是。
闲论能不能在低能的情况下。
回到两场论
即要回到今天的物理。
那这个自洽性是一个判定的方法。
我觉得这个是很合理的。
就是很科学的一件事。
当然也有一些不科学的因素就是。
当这个领域
完全没有实验
没有客观标准的时候。
肯定不会只有一个框架出现。
肯定不会只有一个自洽的框架出现。
这个时候谁做的好谁做的不好。
其实就
依赖于领域那一些老登的主观判断。
你是被谁伤害了是吗？
我也没有被谁伤害。
只是我在那个领域。
但时间越长
就越觉得这件事蠢。
人这一辈子也没多长。
为什么要把自己的时间。
浪费在伺候老登身上。
对
所以感觉是
花了五年学了很多知识。
买了一个大教训
这个教训是
这个大教训就是
要做事业
要做有比较客观品家标准的事。
或者从另一个角度来说。
就是要做对这个世界。
能够产生影响的事。
所以其实你本科还是比较顺利的。
对吧？
在量子物理这个研究领域很快。
你很快就有了非常好的学术成果。
而且是范氏体系的变化。
但是你很快觉得没有心力了。
所以你想造博士去挑战一个更难的事情。
然后在博士期间其实是比较落寞的。
这要从结果来说是这样的。
外界看不出来
外界看都是非常光星的铝点。
博士在戴斯坦菲
对
我觉得从实际的科研产书来说。
我觉得没有人会说我博士期间的文章不好。
但是摸着良心说对这个世界有多大的影响。
我觉得几乎没有影响。
几乎未灵
对我自己来说我自己很不满意的。
但是我觉得确实也没有不满意到说。
我会担心有人说我在昏日子。
确实也没在昏日子。
你还是能达到所有的外界标准的。
对
这怎么做到呢？
我觉得还真的是很多是你冷暖自知对吧？
对
我觉得达到外界标准。
会达到一个小的圈子的评价标准。
是像训练模型一样。
就是一旦有了这么一个小的圈子。
你知道他们的评价标准之后。
做得好是很容易的。
但是
就是其实你哪怕不认可这个标准。
你是可以达到的
但是你还是知道你是不认可的。
因为有时候你哪怕不认可。
你达到了
我也可以蒙蔽自己。
就继续往前走
但我后来就发现我蒙蔽不了自己。
骗不了自己
对
是哪一年发现的
我觉得可能从
不是最后的两年吧？
就会有这样的感觉。
但是那时候确实也没有想好。
没有想清楚如果不做这个该去做什么？
那可能就花一些时间去了解一些不一样的方向。
比如说一开始
我可能更多是去了解是量子计算。
或者量子信息这样的方向。
然后拿了postdoc offer。
就是博后的offer之后。
感觉这个事更紧急了。
因为
在学校里的时候
你还可以一个学生的心态。
离开学校之后就是自己的career。
你得给自己找一条路。
那当时就是觉得
可能量子计算和AR是两条。
我觉得给年轻人
给小灯机会比较多的。
所以你博士后的方向是啥。
博后没有方向
其实就是理论物理这个方向。
博后是一个很独立的职位。
就是你自己想干啥干啥。
对
它更多的是
从某种意义上说要搞慈善。
谁搞慈善
就是有一些可能
不管是在意科研的国家组织。
还是个人组织
它可以给学校捐一笔钱。
或者给学校批一笔钱。
学校用这笔钱来招一些博士后。
在一个系列里面
就做他的研究
然后把自己的研究。
广泛了告诉我系列的别的人。
觉得它更多的是一种。
一种社会的氛围的。
这种工作
对
然后
所以其实没什么限制。
就是你其实想干什么？
就干什么？
但是我其实也没做到。
多长时间的博后
我实际可能到博克里待了两三个月。
但官方来说就只待了两个星期。
官方来说是什么？
我其实在入职之前已经去哪。
因为我反正人就在外面去。
我觉得入职之前就去哪。
但是我入职之后
其实只待了两个星期就辞职了。
对
这两个星期发生了什么？
这两个星期啥也没发生。
我本来都不准备入职的。
但是博克里人就是太好。
没事
就是等事情定了再说。
能来多久就来多久。
你告诉了他们
你其实在跟Enthalpy谈。
对
我告诉他们
其实我觉得我可能会去做AI了。
我要不就别入职了。
博克里
不是博克里
我觉得就是湾区这两个学校的老师。
都人很好
觉得他很照顾你
他就觉得你还没有完全谈定。
那还是先把现在的工作先拿着。
你觉得物理对你后来做AI有什么帮助吗？
我觉得硬实力上其实没什么帮助。
就是存工具圣性的技能上来说。
其实从物理到AI的转化是非常少。
但是我觉得可能非要问的话。
我觉得可能主要的不能说能力吧？
就是性格吧？
可能是可能做物理人会更想跑根问题。
更想理解一个事
然后更想做事很系统。
因为我们习惯的时候很系统性的。
不管是做实验的方式。
还是做理论的方式。
所以我觉得这个可能是一个比较好的地方。
但是我也不觉得这个事是做物理人独特的。
就是为什么做计算机的人没有这个特性。
我觉得我认识很多做计算机的人也有这个特性。
那很多学化学的人也有这个特性。
学生物也也有这个特性。
所以我也不觉得他是做物理独特。
但事实上就是可能比较有趣。
就是这个领域里面确实有很多。
尤其就是原模型这种比较。
就是large scale的这种AI。
确实有很多物理出身的人。
然后做得很成功
尤其是Cocker这个公司。
又很多人在描述这一代AI的时候都会说是黑核。
你能用科学的角度来理解一下这个黑核吗？
就人工智能的运作员。
我觉得这世界上所有东西都是黑核。
就是哪怕像物理这种大家觉得很理解的东西。
其实也并不是真的有一个从它微观的行为一路演化到了宏观体现的这种理解。
像不管是刚才说的large scale两行。
其实都是描述那个能标下的行为。
本质上这个系统还是一个黑核。
你还是不知道它最微观的地方是什么样的东西学。
AI也是一样
就是黑核不黑核其实都是一个相对的事。
我们确实对原模型没有理解到神经科学手术刀级别。
就是不是说我理解这个行为能理解到说这个行为是由于哪一个牛扰。
哪一个人工神经员的哪一个激发产生的这个行为。
没有到这个层面的理解。
除非就是在一些很稀疏很小的网络里面。
就是向上招备有所谓的interoperability。
就可解释性团队
他们可能会做一些类似的工作。
但是在实际能够使用的原模型里都没有达到这样的理解。
但是也不代表我完全没有理解。
比如说skill law它就是一个描述了那个尺度下模型。
随着模型大小和数据是怎么在perplacity。
就是这个指标下变得越来越好。
所以你说是完全没有理解吗？
那如果说skill law不算是理解的一个小部分的话。
那是不是我们也说我们其实对这个世界也完全不理解。
这个世界也是一个完全黑核。
所以skill law是一种科学规律。
它是一种经验规律。
经验规律
但是经验规律和科学规律。
它之间的界限是很模糊的。
比如说我们回头去看这种热力学的各种不一样的定律。
第一定律 第二定律。
克拉伯龙方程 方程 方程 方程 方程 方程这些东西。
在当年被发现的时候也都是经验规律。
但是只是说后来随着时间的发展。
我们慢慢知道了它的微观机制。
那它可能变成了一个科学规律。
我觉得可能像skill law或者类似的这样的东西。
它目前肯定还是很经验的。
但是未来当技术它变得比较固定。
然后大家开始越来越多地理解它微观的过程的时候。
会不会变成一个科学规律。
如果这个定义是存在的话。
我觉得是有可能的。
能不能用科学的表达来解释一下所谓的智能永限。
首先这个话就不太科学。
所以自然也没有办法用科学的话来表达一个不科学的事。
智能有限吗？
对 就是我觉得智能永限对我来说。
它更多的是一种主观的感觉。
而不是一种科观现象。
就是当很多人说智能永限的时候。
他脑袋想的可能是。
以前的语言模型只能做某一个方向的事。
比如说只能翻译
只能做分析
只能做什么？
但现在模型好像可以做所有的事。
但是这个事
我觉得像是对我来说。
它更多的是一个技术上的永限。
而不是一个行为上的永限。
说是我们通过研究发现了。
该怎么去做这种大规模的训练。
然后能够水平的提升所有的能力。
我觉得这个是一个更本质的事。
至于智能永限这个事。
其实我觉得每个人可能心里的定义都不太一样。
你的定义是
对我来说就是没定义。
对我来说
这个唯一一致的区别就是。
有没有发现发生一个技补上的改变。
使得我们可以做skill up。
可以水平的提升所有的能力。
这个对我来说是一个良好定义的事。
你最后是在量子计算和AI之间选择了AI。
这个是怎么发生的变化。
对 我觉得还是花了一些时间。
去了解两个方向的瓶颈在哪。
我觉得
好处是他们都给年轻人机会。
好处是都有机会
但是量子计算对于来说。
好像是离你的主线跟进一阶在那个时候。
这就是为什么要去了解一下细节。
因为了解细节之后就发现不是的。
是反过来的
因为量子这些
不是量子这些
就是量子计算
我觉得它现在的主要瓶颈。
其实在实验上
并不是你怎么去设计那些算法。
或者设计那些算字。
更多的是你怎么在实验上实现它。
那个事反而是我不擅长了。
反而是和我过去很多。
我有兴趣的事
其实是很
比较不相关的
然后反而跟我相关的事是。
更我想AI
就是刚刚说的
AI写的更多的是。
你有一个想法
然后你可以用一些数值去验证。
这个数值在AI里面。
可能就是训练一个模型或者怎么样。
对 然后这个反而和做物理很像。
它甚至是
就是为什么我之前一直。
爱把这个和十八世纪的这个物理学做。
比较就是它
热力学
对 更像那个时代的。
物理就是那个时代的理论和实验不分家。
没有什么理论物理学家。
实验物理学家
你就是搞物理
就是搞物理了
你自己可以做实验。
然后也可以做理论的推测。
我觉得AI就有点像那个时代。
所以其实从理论物理跨越到。
实验物理的距离
比你直接跨到AI要远。
要远
其实要远
而且从兴趣上来说也更远。
你不喜欢实验物理。
你全都实验
我觉得
确实不是我的兴趣所在。
虽然我不自己不愿意做。
但是我确实很有兴趣知道。
别人实验做得怎么样。
不用做实验吗？
用
但是它是更多摄像素质。
对
它不太像那个
就是你实验室去搭一个光学品材。
然后什么？
你还
我觉得实验真的是一个。
就可能因为是我不懂。
我没有达到那个境界。
所以有些事在我看来。
挺玄妙的
比如说
其实大家都知道这个光学品材怎么搭。
但有的人就能给你搭出来。
有的人就是耗了6年都没搭出来。
这个是动手能练
我就是没搞明白
我有时候觉得这是很有点玄妙。
所以还是数值
数值实验
进行很多
对对对
对我来说
做数值实验
或者像AI就是训练模型。
然后研究各种不一样的技巧。
看某些细节
这些事对我来说
反而是我能想明白。
它为什么要这么干。
但是在搭台子这个事上。
我就是一头霧水
你做过是吧？
我
当然就是大家可能都做过基本的。
就独立的人
肯定都做过基本的实验培训。
但是更多就是
有很多做实验的朋友。
然后不管去看他们的实验室。
然后看他们怎么做实验。
还是跟他们聊这些怎么设计实验。
我就感觉很多事
我其实不太能够理解。
但是他们确实有的人。
就是做得好
有的人做的就是不好。
所以你说现在从事AI研究。
像17世纪热力学研究。
其实在表达
虽然大家没有办法很清晰的。
从科学上去解释和理解这个事情。
但是它并不会阻止它发展。
对
就是它更像是在
为什么比较那个时代热力学。
就是那个时代大家其实。
不理解什么是热的微观理论。
大家不知道热是什么东西。
就像现在不能理解。
对
就像现在大家不能理解。
这个Language Model里面。
那一个举证员是在干什么？
其实大家也不理解。
但是不妨碍你有一些好的经验定律。
比如热力学的各种定律。
和现在的各种skating law。
所以说从这个角度来说是。
就从这个方向的角度来说是。
这个层面上来说它是类似。
然后从研究人员的角度来说。
就是刚才说的另外一问题。
就是它里面和实验器不太分家。
嗯
对
那你是怎么去面试。
anthropic。
这个anthropic的历程是怎么展开的。
我觉得
其实主要还是因为有前同事在anthropic。
前同事
对
就是anthropic其实有很多做无理书人。
尤其是做理论无理书生的人。
为什么呀？
就是他们从人的选择上。
为什么会选择这一拨人。
我觉得
当然就是很多
很多人可能会找一些原因说。
做无理人擅长这个或者擅长那个。
但是
就我个人的视角来看。
我觉得主要的原因还是connection。
就是联系
就是因为anthropic的创始团队里面。
创始团队里面其实有三。
当时有三四个比较。
比较技术的人
然后其中有两个现在还。
还很在技术一线领导的人。
他们两个都是做无理出身的。
然后他们可能招的一些人。
也是做无理出身的。
所以就这样一直延续下来。
但其实到了现在这个阶段。
就在我之后
其实也几乎没怎么再招。
完全没有AI背景的人了。
对
所以说也是一个
我觉得也是一个时代的产物。
对
然后我反正是当时。
我决定去做AI了。
所以我就
就设出去联系一些地方。
然后
你只找了啊？
dropic吗？
没有
我还找了OpenAI和纪点。
就goodymind。
但goodymind。
因为他那时候速度太慢了。
所以就没有
最后没有出现在考虑的范围内。
但是
速度太慢了
是指他们面试的速度慢。
但是后来
显然后来咱们俩这个事。
就获得了长足的提升。
后来动手就非常快。
然后
dropic就是。
OpenAI呢？
OpenAI也行。
但是OpenAI可能没有找到。
特别合适的是合而人。
然后
dropic是因为我。
当时联系了
后来就是我的第一任。
那个manager。
我第一任经理
然后他以前也是做这个。
理论物理的
然后他当时
就说
我们在茶室做墙花学习。
茶室做这种大规模墙花学习。
有很多科学问题
要去理解
那个时候
24年
9月
89月的时候
那个时候
其实墙花学习还没有现在。
这么成熟
那时候大多数
其实都不太知道怎么做。
因为O1其实还没发布呢？
那时候
O1只是
快发了
对对对
就是就是只是
只是大家都知道有。
但是大家都还没看到结果。
但是dropic当时。
其实不知道怎么做的。
当时是
大体上知道
但是有很多细节需要仔细去研究。
然后
所以他就跟我说
哎有这么一个事
你要不要来面试一下。
然后我觉得
他觉得
哎可能是一个好的机会。
你当时怎么认知墙花学习。
没认知
你大概知道
Print损词
Post损词
我大概知道这个流程。
但我其实不太知道。
具体的这种
这种工业级的
别的圆墨性是怎么训练的。
只能知道
就是像学术节是怎么训练的。
对
然后
所以其实
现在谈的那时候的认知。
其实在我现在看来。
就是没有认知
嗯
对
然后
更多的还是
我倒是觉得这个事是一个。
不确定的事
然后是一个好的机会。
所以我就去干了
对
当然也有些面试的。
准备和面试过程
对
怎么准备的
聊啥
我当时
跟谁面的
早就后来我的一些同事。
当时面的
然后
面试题也不太难
反正
对
但是对我来说
我也我当时也不知道怎么准备。
然后我就去把
我能找到的那些课。
自己能学的学了一遍。
然后能做的做也做了一遍。
然后
自己手错了一套
就是那个
Android Capacity。
它有一个著名的那个项目叫。
好像叫拿到GPT也还叫什么？
反正就是它有一个。
可以在一个
Google这个collab notebook里面。
就能训论一个很小的GPT模型。
然后我就
手错了一下那个
然后就去面了
嗯
对
然后很快拿到的offer。
然后就
对
然后就拿到offer。
然后你第一方
就是大规模的墙块学习。
也当时其实是有
两个组
来
两个组的manager。
来跟我聊
一个是做evaluation。
就是模型评测
然后另外也开始做墙块学习。
然后我是选择了墙块学习。
你当时选择的墙块学习。
是因为它更加的不明了。
对
嗯
然后那时候
其实Android也不像现在是一个大公司。
那时候公司其实也很像。
多人
我去的时候
我们的那个大的team。
才只有10个人左右。
不是10个人或者11个人反正。
大team叫什么？
叫horizon。
哦
对
然后那个时候那个大team。
也就
这个大team的平行team有什么？
那个大team其实后来。
几乎就是
墙块学习的方法面面。
都在这个team了。
哦
对
但那时候
整个大组就是一个墙块学习。
整个大组
首先这个创业公司。
你也很难说
这个组的目标是什么？
因为它
可能曾经也有过
很多不一样的目标。
但只是那个阶段
可能主要的目标是做墙块学习。
对
然后
当然底下也有做更。
更数据的
组
更做
环境和
和infra
和记录说师的组
也有
更做这种
research。
和
和算法的组
然后我去的那个组。
是比较偏research和算法的组。
嗯
那时候啊？
Dropik多少人。
啊？
那个时候可能
七八百的样子
总共
但是
对
整个的公司
七八百
对
你一进去对这家公司。
印象是什么呢？
我觉得
我觉得我对养消费的印象。
其实还是挺
就挺consistent。
就是
我觉得进去之后
我觉得公司的印象就是。
执行力非常强
就是
它其实是一个
比较逃不上的公司。
对
然后
所以很多事情
决定了之后
就会全力去做
然后
公司其实
员工之间的
的氛围也很好
就大家都
不会藏在业者
然后
尤其刚去的时候很小嘛？
所以
就是大家也都认识。
所以就
氛围很好
然后
我觉得
如果是
做
只是做语言模型相关的事的话。
其实
现在回头来看
那是一个
非常非常好的学习机会。
就是你能够接触到。
这个模型训练的方方面面。
然后
都能找到对你的人去问。
对
那个时候的
anthropic已经有了。
现在我们都知道
它那个非常
坚定的
Batt了吗？
有了
有的
这个Batt来自于哪里。
为什么会有这个Batt。
我不知道它
完全的来源在哪
我自己能看到的
一个显然的来源
就是
前一代模型
Cloud3放了之后。
推特上
那时候可能还没叫X呢？
推特上有很多人在。
讨论说
那个Cloud3好像写Code比GV4强。
那个年代
GV4还是一个
和大家概谱很大的模型。
所以能有一件
重要的事比GV4强。
就很
厉害了
所以是试出来的
我觉得至少是
其中一个原因
就是是
是很快的
对这个市场做了反馈。
对
这也是
我觉得这个公司
很强的一点
就是它
exclusion执行力。
非常非常强
一旦给它一个信号。
让它觉得是很
reasonable。
这公司该做的事
那就会
铺上去
它没有那些
大组织内容用于
为什么它的coding会比GV4要好。
不能说
是有原因的
是有原因
对
但是是个随机的原因。
不是一个我这么选择。
所以有了这个结果的原因。
是一个纯技术原因。
但是
确实我不
我不能确定一开始。
是随机世找的
还是故意选择的
你要让我猜
我肯定会觉得是随机世找的。
纯技术的原因
是有某个人做了某个事情。
是确实有某一个团队。
做了某个事情
是自杀而下的
还是自杀而上的
我觉得最开始
可能是自杀而上的。
但是后来就变成
自杀而下的事
就是要快速捕捉到一些市场。
内部和市场的型号。
对
我觉得这个是
然后要赶快要铺上去。
对
我觉得这是埃萨贝非常非常强的一点。
他非常非常的reactive。
反应非常快
他执行来自于哪里。
来自于DARL这个人。
来自于他的某种特质。
我感觉就是
埃萨贝作为一个公司来说。
他能够实现这种
就是比较Top Down的机制。
是一个很独特的事。
为什么？
因为
实现Top Down。
其实有一个很难的点。
就是你做技术的决策人。
必须也得是公司本身的决策人。
首先就是你技术上。
得能服众
那下面的研究员才会。
你才能够就是
幸福下面的研究员。
去做这个事
另一方面就是
你得是公司的决策人。
你得能为这个公司负这个责任。
埃萨贝有这个条件。
就是说他的
技术上的leader的领导人。
其实是公司的口方的。
是你指的是谁
不是达瑞
就是杰瓦尔卡普兰和SAM。
然后像他们俩
就是公司的口方的。
然后他们自己做这个决定。
那是人家的公司
所以他有权利做的。
是Top Down的事。
那达瑞作为CEO。
他会CES很弄吗？
我不知道
他们决策层的讨论里面。
达瑞有起到什么样的作用。
我只能说
就技术里的人是有决定权的。
我只能说对我
当时的工作来说
我接触的最多就是杰瓦尔卡。
可是这对于SAM模型公司很难吗？
很难
比如说OPI就干不了。
一俩在的时候难得不行吗？
一俩在的时候有可能可以。
但是一俩后来
一方面
我也不知道
因为什么原因
他就是失去了这个。
做决策的能力
然后就走了
所以就
其他公司呢？
其他公司我觉得都比较难。
就是占卖也比较难。
但是我觉得占卖就是另外一套打法。
不太一样
就是说
我觉得就是打公司和start-up。
打法本来就不一样。
因为start-up重要的是make that。
就是我得赌一件事。
我如果想要赌
就意味着有风险
所以就意味着
我能够去很快的做一些决策。
然后很强力的推进一些决策。
那可能在这种情况下。
掏不上我觉得是一个很有优势的事。
所以我觉得
它会比从组织上来说。
是比我还要更有优势。
但是作为大公司来说。
它可能就是另外一套想法。
因为大公司的想法可能是。
我不仅能尽量减少做赌的成分。
而是我能在方方面面都有储备。
然后任何一个事成了。
我都能跟上
然后如果有事我自己做成了。
我可能还能理先
这可能大公司应该。
所以说在Germany。
Google是一个很传统的。
就很Bottom up的组织。
就是公司从面可能有一些。
比较良好定义的框架来。
来看你的工作是好是坏。
来引导你做一些公司需要的事。
但是本质上还是你自己来决定自己的做手。
所以你觉得Enthropic能 make bath。
是因为它的赌特的文化。
组织和文化对
这个听起来其实应该是其他公司也能做的。
但是却非常奇怪的发现。
在公司很难做
而Enthropic可以做到。
对 我觉得还是需要技术的。
或者公司的leader有公信力。
这个其实挺难的 我觉得。
你说的还不是CEO有公信力。
是技术的一号位有公信力。
对 我对我来说
我觉得技术的一号位有公信力很重要。
但是与此同时CEO可能没有成为一个阻力。
对
这个难吗？
这个我觉得就得看你这个口方定的这个team。
有没有足够的互相信任。
这个也很关键
我觉得ISOV这点也是在START2被很强了。
就是它口方定team没有一个人离开公司。
他们如果你看能不能过去距离。
那就是那是一群真正一起打过仗的人。
就过去
他们源自于
他们都是以前UQI的一群。
UQI
对 然后像他们甚至好多人都是。
就是在一系列关键的文章上的合注者。
因为你像Skin and Law这个paper是。
Jerard Kaplan 然后San。
然后当然还有W
然后还有一些可能Tom Brown也在吧？
我不太记得Tom Brown在不在。
然后CBD3的paper就是Tom Brown在。
然后Ben
Ben Lyne在。
然后Jerard和San也都在。
W也都在
所以他们是一块
爬过站好的人
我觉得互相之间的信任还是很关键。
有很多公司可能就是。
干得干着连这个小集体都团结不住了。
那你怎么能指望这个大公司能团结住呢？
你再说我不来是吧？
你加入Undropic公司。
正在做的最重要的项目是什么？
你参与到那个大项目里面了吗？
对 就是当时就是为了。
能做大尺度的签划学习。
然后能够用它来提高coding的能力。
这个就是当时最重要的事。
然后我们当时做这个组。
当时的研究重心就是一个事。
这个组为什么后来就慢慢变大。
然后变越来越重要的原因。
然后最终带来的结果就是。
大家一块吹了这个3.7。
Cloud 3.7这个模型。
你说内部脚有一个3.6。
这个是
不是内部脚
就是外界的Cloud 3.5其实有两个版本。
一个可能是6月的版本。
另外一个10月的版本。
然后
你也可以看出
安超费这个公司曾经也是没啥产品能力的。
居然管两个模型叫一个名字。
所以后来外面人为了区分。
管那个3.5后面那个版本叫3.6。
所以安超费跟随着外面的这个习惯。
就叫3.6了
管这个再新的模型叫做3.7。
所以就是你去看实际的这个公司的产品时间。
像其实3.5
3.5.6 3.7。
怎么会有一个3.5.6。
这个是怎么想的
你去
不只能说那个时候的安超费。
可能真的是没有什么产品上的想法。
所以你第一个项目是3.7还是3.5。
3.7还是3.5.6。
3.5.6其实我。
没参与
几乎没参与
因为它
3.5.6就已经看到了coding的迹象是吗？
你刚才刚开始的
3.5.6的时候已经看出了。
Software的模型在Azure Coding会比别的模型强了。
这个是为什么？
所以你进去的时候刚刚好。
就是他们有
他们知道了这件事情。
就是管理才也知道了这个迹象。
然后他们要make bath的时候。
你这个运气很好
我觉得对
我觉得我进去的时候是。
大家肯定已经看到这个事。
能做成且重要
但是不太清楚怎么去把它做成。
然后我去的时候是跟大家一起去研究怎么把它做成。
对
所以方法是大尺度的强化学习。
对这是
从大的角度来说是。
但是当然就是有很多技术细节。
是需要去研究的
这是没有什么弄好。
有好多NDA的内容呢？
NDA社会写的这么详细的吗？
其实原则上来说
原则上来说
我员工是不能在
在指期间和离职之后。
透露任何跟公司内部相关的信息的。
当然实际上来说
就是大家可能心里都有一个度。
就是说
如果这个技术没有公开的话。
肯定是不会公开去谈的。
但是我觉得虽然我不能公开去谈。
但是我
我觉得把简单的事做得比谁都干净。
是最关键的
什么叫干净啊？
你刚才用过这个词。
对
就是我觉得有很多花丽胡哨的技巧。
比如说做强化学习。
最简单的奖励就是。
Politic Brilliant。
但是不代表这是唯一的奖励。
它还有别的算法
比如说各种复杂的。
这种搜索算法之类的东西。
但是
是不是这些复杂性是必须的。
然后这些复杂性可能给你带来的一些。
一些业非甚至也就是效率上的提升。
它可能给你带来一些。
比如说基建infra上的困难。
那你怎么去推到复这些事。
这些事其实做研究需要去理解的。
就是怎么去balance这种不同的因素。
然后选到最好的那一套。
最稳定的那条路
对
然后我觉得很多的浓号。
其实都是在这些细节里面。
怎么去处理这方方面的细节里面。
对
那时候怎么来描述。
coding很重要呢？
我觉得
他认为是大圆模型的一个分支。
一个重要的分支还是什么呢？
我觉得每个人可能想法不一样。
对我来说
对我来说他重要的原因。
有二
一个原因就是
一个原因大事
曹北一直在讲的事。
就是说coding本身也是。
做圆模型研究的一部分。
如果你能够把coding做得很好。
那可能会让你的研究效率。
有范围的提升
就形成一个
研究上的费轮了
这是一方面的原因。
对我来说另一方面的原因是因为。
coding其实是模型使用工具。
和环境交互的一个很好的抽象。
首先这个抽象
刚刚已经说过的就是这个抽象的好复杂。
比如说回归信号清晰。
然后
然后数据充分
其实你是很
很难在别的场景下找到能同时有。
这两个特质的使用工具场景。
所以对我来说这是一个好抽象。
在这里面做的一些研究。
可能是对更通用的那些使用工具和环境交互的。
能力的一些有用的。
有用的lesson。
有用的课
那时候Cursor是什么状态。
那时候Cursor还是一个存产品公司。
我觉得从某种意义上来说。
好像
在我去演到之前的那段时间里。
Cloud和Cursor都属于。
比较underdog的状态。
然后
3号在3.5new。
就是外界的3.6。
这一代的时候
首先是这个模型能力上去。
然后Cursor又发现这个模型真的能够做了。
这种Azure Coding的工具了。
它也是一个壳
对
但是这个壳包含着一个模型。
一下子让公众体会到了。
不是公众
公众设计就是软件工程那个圈子。
体会到了
这事好像是真的是效率工具了。
所以后来就是这个一下就起来了。
在那个时候
他就underdog就意识到。
Cursor是未来的清晨对手。
那就不知道
该问大Rail
3.7是怎么做出来的。
这个是一个分水灵。
对underdog来说是一个分水灵式的模型。
我觉得对于underdog的后训练来说。
是一个分水灵
就是在3.7之前。
后训练都是处于一个比较。
比较小规模
然后可能就是修修补补模型的。
这种一个状态
大家不重视后训练是吗？
也不是不重视
就是一开始
大家其实很长时间。
大家都没有搞明白。
后训练该怎么skill up。
但是在那个阶段
不管是open eyes or surfing。
还是包括像中国的deep seek。
大家意识到了这个事。
该怎么去skill up。
该怎么skill up。
就是你得找到合适的环境。
这个环境
它的回馈信号足够的清晰。
然后这个环境本身。
也是一个很强的数据源。
然后在这个上面
其实能让这个训练非常稳定。
这事就能做成
对 我记得那个时候。
其实大家都不知道。
open eyes的保密项目是什么？
就知道它的草莓叫strawberry。
然后大家觉得会带来一个新的范图。
新的范图就是后训练的强化学习。
但是更多的就不知道了。
对 其实
我觉得我去strawberry的时候。
大家已经比较清楚这个事。
大概该怎么做
就是大概的这个方向是怎么做。
然后当然后来
就是后来随着
我对这个领域知道越来越多之后。
就发现其实那个时刻。
其实open eyes做的方式和strawberry。
其实还是差别挺大的。
这么说
就是具体这种算法。
和使用数据的方式其实是不太一样的。
虽然都叫后训练和强化学习。
虽然都要领
但是当然我觉得那些不是本质区别。
就是大的方向来说。
他们是同一个
就是找一些
找一些这种很回归心扫。
非常清楚 非常客观。
然后数据本身又比较干净。
然后对于模型来说是可学习的。
然后在上面做稳定的强化学习心理。
大的方向来说都是这个方向。
但具体实现其实是差别比较大。
但后来事实也证明。
就是具体实现其实每家方向都不一样。
但是都能做成
而且当时open eyes目标也不是coding。
当时我了解到的趋势是说。
预训练作为第一个方式已经金矿快挖完了。
所以我们现在要开启第二个金矿。
就是后训练和强化学习。
然后来让skine law继续。
对 我觉得很长时间open eyes都是这个想法。
我不知道他们现在想法有没有变。
我觉得对我来说我的想法经历过摇摆。
在三转型那个时代我其实觉得。
我当时也抱着这个预训练已经快party is over这种感觉。
然后就在你绕入职的时候什么？
对 我刚入职
然后当时在做这种三转型相关的这种实验的时候。
我当时也曾经抱过这个想法。
但是后来随着了解越来越深。
我就觉得发现就是其实还有做的空间了。
然后预训练skine law这个事。
它也不是告诉你你要一直变大。
它其实本身上是一个很系统的框架。
能够告诉你做什么样的事是更有效的。
对
然后最后来就发现其实还有很多做事。
然后事实情况是后来。
苏卫和詹姆奈的预训练也一直在不断的进展。
我发现自己卡了很久。
他现在又重视预训练了吗？
他应该已经重视预训练停久了。
就是最近可能刚刚有点进展。
所以预训练和后训练作为两个饭室。
都没有达到他的那个平台起。
我觉得都没有
但是你说要去预测到了多少这个做不到。
对 我觉得到达平台期有两种可能性。
一种可能性是技术本身到达。
就是你明明还有想让模型要干的事。
但是这俩技术就死活消不会了。
另一种可能性是你想干的事到平台期了。
我就现在就负责
就是我们现在知道了。
有一个插bot
你可以叫他干这个。
然后又有一个coding。
后面就不知道了
对 就不知道该交点他啥好。
就是说这模型还是一个非常聪明的小孩。
你其实可以教他很多东西。
但是我们人类作为老师。
现在还不知道下一个东西该教什么？
对 或者说该怎么去合理地教他。
用现在的一些饭食。
说到3.7 还有什么东号。
这是几个月做出来的。
这个最后00总总。
从开始训练到发布。
可能花了四五个月的样子吧？
就是从你刚进去
就是从开始
大家为了这个事做研究。
那可能花了两三个月。
然后后来开始训练。
到训练结束中间
柯哥办办很多事情要处理。
然后有很多新的据补说师。
其实据补说师真的是很重要。
很花时间
然后又可能花了可能两个月这样。
你在举用做的重要的工作是什么？
我觉得我也没什么重要的。
我觉得我对我个人的贡献。
我觉得我个人对任何一个模型的贡献。
我的成熟都是
我觉得我自己对那个事没那么重要。
我觉得我更多的是。
我很幸运
有机会在那个时候。
加入了一个重要的项目。
做了一些事
因为从某种意义上来说。
我觉得AI
在现在最近这几年。
这个事本身是一个不可阻挡的事。
它不在于你这个人去干或者不干。
你不干
也有别人一样能干出来了。
所以我觉得
在这个时代其实
所有给个人贴金的事。
其实都有点炒作的嫌疑。
但是确实我觉得
对我来说我是很幸运。
能在那个阶段
加入了一个重要的事。
学习了一些知识
好的
那你在幸运的在那个阶段。
在Altropic之家公司的。
大尺度强化学习的这个团队里。
做了什么？
我觉得3.7那时候。
可能主要做的还是。
就是在ARO里做Agentic Coding。
这件事
这件事怎么把它screw off。
或者怎么去准备各样。
就是怎么去制备各种各样的环境和data。
然后包括算法上
会遇到什么样的问题。
当时主要的研究都在这部分。
这里有什么tips吗？
现在来看梅莎特别有用的tips。
我觉得说技术的tips。
其实这个事是一个。
大家一方面很愿意听。
公司又不让你说
但实际又没啥用的事。
为什么？
因为很多算法设计。
其实并不鼓励独立算法。
它是非常强的依赖运营的技术设施。
举个简单的例子
就是有些公司
他可能就大家经常讨论。
有一个问题就是说。
在强好学习时候
这个sample。
就是给你产生这些trace。
这些token的机器。
和trainer。
用来实际训练这个模型。
然后改变这个模型全中的机器。
这样的机器可能会有不一样。
但是不一样
有一些原因是因为数值上的不一样。
有一些原因是因为。
使用一种异步的训练架构。
所以说它自然就是。
从根本上来说就不一样。
那你不同公司
可能这个不一样程度是不一样。
所以你算法上设计也会不一样。
有些公司他可能
这个这两个difference。
这两个区别非常非常大。
那你算法可能最大的部分。
就是在于怎么控制这个。
然后怎么让这个训练稳定。
可能对于训练的这个实际的效果之类的。
全中就会稍微小一点。
但有可能有了公司。
它的机构设施现实就特别特别好。
这两个差别没那么大。
那可能就可以花更多精力。
在这个训练效果上。
所以说
很多众统小的tabs是。
其实是没什么用的。
就很多node号其实是没什么用的。
因为我确实也发现了。
就是很多别的lab。
就不是在这三家lab里面。
可能很想知道
艾萨贝尔怎么做这个。
或者詹麦尔怎么做那个。
但其实我有时候不愿意回答一个主要原因。
是因为我觉得
本质上我回答这个问题。
也是在误导它
就是现代的AI训练是一个大系统。
你其实要把
要了解这个系统的方方面面。
才能有一个全局的认识什么事。
是因为什么而变得有用了。
而不是说这个事本身有用。
从3.7到4.5又发生什么呢？
这个预选了后院的都有。
然后
当然就是一个就是sql app上做的更多了。
然后data
不管是data还是训练的。
这个算力都更大的赤路了。
但是我觉得从饭式上来说。
就没有特别大的改变。
到你离开anthropic的时候。
它已经断了
接近两千人了吧？
扩了一倍多
所以你在anthropic时期。
更好使它最具列转变的一个事情。
我可能就采在了
它还是个小公司的尾巴。
其实我觉得进去之后。
过了可能三四个月。
这个公司就已经开始。
一下就变多了
文化有变化吗？
还是经历一些比较混沌的阶段吧？
然后可能
尤其可能就是在我离开的那段。
快离开的那段时间。
我觉得文化上还是经历了一些混沌。
因为从外面来了一些人。
然后可能根本本来的文化有一些冲突。
对
然后
之前的文化是
我觉得之前就是
比较简单
对就很简单
就是它更像是一个小作坊。
大家都是朋友
然后大家都知道对方在干嘛？
然后也没有人特别。
特别会
就是做过多的这种个人宣传。
还是怎么做一些没有用的事。
也没有人做没有用的事。
大家都是有很多事要处理。
然后公司那时候
可能紧迫感也更强一些吧？
然后后来可能就
就这样人多了
这样的文化
感觉会受到一些冲击。
带来的什么风气
我觉得确实有一些人。
我个人不是很喜欢。
当然你不代表他们真的不好。
就是我个人不是很喜欢。
就是可能我不太喜欢。
在这个领域里面说很多话的人。
就是那个
我觉得idea is cheap。
想法是便宜的
很多想法其实很显然。
所有人都知道
难的是怎么把实现。
怎么把它变成一个一个小的。
可实现的步骤
把它做出来
我觉得我不太喜欢那些。
一天中很多时间
花在slack
就是slack是美国用的。
一个办公的这种软件。
然后在slack上花很多时间。
在那讲一些大道理。
我觉得就是没啥用。
你后来为什么突然离职了。
你是完成了什么？
階段性的工作吗？
当时
酝酿了多久
我觉得可能酝酿了。
一两个月
一个多月吧？
一个月多一点
然后
对
我觉得
一个方面
就是我其实
不是太特别认同
大家有反华这个事。
我觉得他
作为一个公司的CEO来说。
对他个人来说
他做什么样的观点。
我觉得都无所谓
但是作为一个公司的CEO来说。
我觉得把这个观点。
推到这么极端的地步。
是一个非常情绪化的体现。
对
然后这是一个比较小的原因。
当然大的方面
有很多公司
刚才说的公司的文化上。
有些冲击
然后包括我自己可能。
也想去学习一些不一样的事情。
就说
iZalbit他毕竟非常的专注。
然后你可能做
如果你想想做
和原卧性相关的方方面面。
然后做这种使用工具。
这种agenture。
然后coding这种事。
那在iZalbit其实很好。
能学到很多东西
但是iZalbit有很多不做的事。
比如说iZalbit。
完全没有人做这种动作才生成。
你想学没地学
然后iZalbit可能也没有花太多的精力。
在这种更底层的工程的技术设施上。
对
所以可能想要学习更多的东西。
也是我当时厉害的一个动力。
嗯
对
仿华占百分之多少比例。
因为他我有个个人原因。
我在公开场合是有百分之四十。
但是这个数字反正就是听听就好。
这个数字就是告诉你。
它不是主要原因
但它确实是一个很大的原因。
对
就没有控股
不是个控股原因
对
但是是一个
Majority Holder的原因。
哈哈
嗯
你这个选择也很神奇。
因为大多数人在一个。
他还是一个underdog的时候加入。
会更有感情
然后会愿意陪公司走更长时间。
但你反而跳去了google。
因为很多研究原因。
你一进去google。
他会觉得google给的scope不够。
嗯
所以他会反而想跳去。
像xzi或者anthropic这样的。
更小一点的组织
你这个行动好像也是反的。
对
我觉得其实取决你自己想要的是什么？
如果你很想要的是。
我有一个很明确的像你说的。
很明确的scope。
然后这个事和我的最后产品的模型。
息息相关
我一定要把我其中的一个想法。
送到这个模型里去。
嗯
那可能google是一个很差的地方。
因为毕竟有那么多的研究员。
有那么多已经成熟的组织。
做这件事情是
很有很有很复杂的这个过程。
嗯
但是我觉得
germany很。
如果你想要的是你有研究的自由。
有探索的自由
然后想去能
从更广泛的人类学习。
我觉得这个世界上可能找不到。
第二个比germany更强的地方。
所以
所以就是
我觉得本身上还是取决。
你要自己想要什么？
嗯
但是我觉得很多人离职。
不管从哪离职
换到另外一家之后。
可能会觉得不开心的主要原因。
是因为没想明白自己想要什么？
比如说
你要是到了google。
你可能该是
如果你刚开始想的是。
我要有研究自由
然后学
更多的动机是学习。
然后你去了之后发现。
还是想要有产品
产品impact。
那你可能就会很难受。
你不追求impact吗？
你在
你也可说这个现在这个as。
是一个非常大的系统。
然后是一个
很大量的人写作的一个。
东西
你在里面追求什么？
我觉得分阶段
就是我觉得
在ansobe经历了太多这个。
和产品息息相关的事之后。
我可能也想给自己换个脑子。
去学习一些不一样的东西。
但是你说有没有哪一天。
我可能又换回这个脑子。
又想去产生一些产品的影响。
也没有可能的
产品影响力怎么那样的话。
这个内部都很清晰是吗？
不好聊话
就是我觉得
因为发论文的时候。
它还是有一做
这种作者
主导作者
现在呢？
其实没有办法聊话。
实际情况就是没有办法聊话。
这也是为什么？
我觉得在这个时代。
其实谈每一个个人。
个体的影响是一个很。
很虚无伤秒的事情。
我觉得本质上还是这个组织。
做了这样一件事
或者这个世界需要这样。
所以产生产品影响是个主观感受。
在模型测质上是这样。
在模型测质上这样。
对
然后
当然实际上你可以。
我觉得可以细节谈的是说。
你
自己做过哪些事情。
具体的技术的贡献。
然后它在技术上产生的效果。
这个是可以客观的去谈论的。
但是比较主观的事是。
你说这个效果
在最后的产品里占了多下的笔众。
这个没有人能说清楚。
对
而且3.7上你的描述一下吗？
我觉得
你觉得什么样的技术性的工作。
对模型是产生了一下。
主要还是跟隐身的。
coding的环境有关的。
工作
然后也有一些算法上。
算法上主要是
怎么让这个训练变得更。
更
就更稳定说实话
就是
但是
我觉得算法上
肯定是有一些提升。
但是也没有达到特别理想的效果。
说实话
比之前的算法肯定是要好的。
但是
那个我觉得也不是我个人的贡献。
我觉得也是大家集体的贡献。
对
我每次问你
你都会说这是集体的贡献。
不是一个个人英雄主义的时代。
我觉得跟英雄主义时代。
对于蓝柜之猫的来说可能过去了。
什么时候是
就是在
transformer那个时刻。
对
就是在那个技术
我还没到screw up那个点之前。
那找到了那个技术的人。
可能是一个英雄
或者找到那个技术的一个小团队。
可能是个英雄
找到那个技术之后。
可能很长的一段时间。
从模型测来说
都是
我觉得更多的是集体主义。
就是这个集体能不能一起工作。
能不能为了一个目标。
一起
花自己的时间
花自己的精力
这个是最重要的事。
而不是每一个个人。
提供了什么样的东西。
说集体主义的原因是因为。
其实能力是来自于AI是吗？
说集体主义的原因。
是因为我觉得AI这个方向。
本质上是简单
就是没有哪
我觉得没有哪个
除了可能跳遍了一下。
那个idea可能是得有一些。
很深刻的动荐
在之后的那个过程中。
很多想法其实是非常。
tribute
就是非常愚蠢的
就是谁都能想
谁都能干
只是你预计好
撞到这个机会去干了而已。
包括你在描述
anthropy做coding。
好像它也是某种随机型。
但是你要抓住它
对
但是我觉得做coding。
可能还比做模型测的这些。
记录上的东西
可能还更稍微有点公私。
英雄主义
就是说你能不能足够快的。
做这件事
那确实还是一个人。
作为很强
但如果今天没有anthropy。
做
可能别的公司也做了。
我觉得是
就是是一个必然的事。
所以它都是AI在永远能力。
对
我觉得
就是看你能不能抓住。
那个能力
不管是公司还是个挺。
对
我觉得就是在
在这个可用的圆模型。
大致的圆模型出现之前。
那个时候
很多事情是一个非必然。
就是有没有一个人。
能够发明一个圆模型。
能够大致不做训练。
然后以及gbt这个饭食。
能不能被发现出来。
那是有很多不确定性的。
但是你说
比如那个时候
你说如果没有google bring。
那可能transformer就。
不会被发现
可能要过很多很多年。
才会另外一个
有钱又有人的组织发现。
那可能就是一个很大的影响。
但是进入那个阶段之后。
尤其到现在
已经反过来
就是
你任何一个组织想要。
停止AI进展
是做不到的
所以
按道别有
因为按道别很担心AI安全。
那按道别有没有这个能力。
阻止AI发展
它没有
你阻止发展
你停止发展
别人会发展
你的话语权还会变小。
对
其实现在是
其实更多是这样一种状态。
这个世界在推着我们的前进。
而不是我们在推着这个世界前进。
感觉未来我们会更加难以阻止。
我觉得已经阻止不了。
就是我觉得
试图去阻止AI里的一件事。
可能本身就不是一种正确的想法。
这也是
就是刚才聊到
因为刚才聊到的时候。
按道别
就是按道别
其中一个很重要的动因。
是所谓AI安全
我觉得它
在AI安全之事
这样摄像
还创立的时候动因。
对
现在跟它有什么关系。
现在的关系比较复杂。
就是说
一个自然的问题是。
大家可能会问
一个做AI安全的公司。
为什么现在开始训前沿模型了。
按道别的解释是说。
我首先得拥有一个最前沿的模型。
我才有话语权来推进我的AI安全。
所以说
它其实一直以来的想法是说。
我要做这个摄像最好的模型。
你大家不得不听我的。
来推进我的安全政策。
但其实
从我个人角度来说。
我觉得这个想法是非常幼稚。
这个事现在
看来它是不会发现。
不会发生
更有可能发生
就是大家都有很好的前沿模型。
而你没有办法阻止这个任何事发生。
对
觉得可能
对于这个事来说
现在更多关注的
更多该想的事是
如果你真的想避免AI带来一些危机。
什么才是一个更自动化的事。
对
举一个自动化的例子就是。
比如说核武器就是。
核武器也是一个可以。
大家觉得
可能有毁灭世界力量的事。
但核武器最后最终受到控制的方法。
就是Multiparty Control。
就是这样
大家有很多个有核武器的国家。
他们互相都有毁灭对方的能力。
所以通过这样一种制衡。
才稳定住
我觉得你要阻止AI。
干一些不好的事
可能最终是需要一种。
类似的机制来实现的。
而不是希望
既希望说一家公司。
制定一个法律而干一件事。
对
而且还自己制定
它也只能管得了自己。
对
你刚才也提到
DrawPick有个可解释性团队。
是吗？
这个它的可解释性到达哪一步了。
在一些比较简单
然后比较稀松的
的神经网络里面
他们能够做一些有趣的研究。
比如说
看看某一个输出了。
或者输入的文字
或者图片
它的内在的表示是长成什么样子。
然后你可能把那个表示什么？
反一下之后
它会能输出一个什么样的东西。
做一下这样的研究。
你刚才还提到一个观点。
就是AI本质是简单的。
你这个能描述一下这句话。
这是一个结论
对 我觉得
这甚至不是一个结论。
就是这是我的一个statement。
这是我的一个陈述。
它可对可错
然后我对这个
这是你的观点
对
我对这个陈述的解释是。
我觉得它本质上简单的点。
在于它能做实验
就是它和比如说
本质上的难的东西。
比如说物理
它的区别在于
那个东西
你没有那个能标下的实验数据。
你就是理解不了那个能标下的理论。
但是AI不被这个所棒的。
目前
你理解不了没关系。
我也可以往前发展。
而且就是我现在事实就是。
能够做任何我能想到的实验。
只是可能说
我需要一些时间去把这个计算量提上来。
或者把这个计算设施准备好。
但是没有什么本质上的困难。
对
所以
无疑之后就是
就是觉得AI
就是没有给人感觉。
它碰壁的原因就是。
首先很多东西你都能试。
其次
现在不是说
大家已经想空了脑袋。
没有什么想法可以试了。
更多的情况下
是有太多的想法
得一个个试
花时间
对
感觉真好渺小
在这个实验面前
是的
所以说
我觉得
很快可能AI就会开始自己做实验了。
很快就多快
四个月内
我觉得未来的六到十二个月。
AI就会自己做实验。
我觉得其实
当然就是这话不太良好定义。
对不起我说了一个很模糊的话。
就是
AI自己提高自己或者自己来。
加快自己的发展
过程这件事
其实已经在发生了。
对吧？
像我们刚刚最早说了过。
就是他已经开始帮我们能够。
去实现一些
一些我们想要的东西。
然后加快我们实验的速度。
但是我觉得
未来六到十二
他目前还做不到的事情是什么？
是说他能不能
从头到尾的
把一件AI研究的事做完。
就比如说
他不仅能写这个code。
他还能跑这个实验。
跑这个实验
还能看到这个结果。
看到这个结果
还能分析这个结果。
分析这个结果
知道他哪儿做的不对。
然后提出新的假设。
设计新的代码
跑新的实验
这个这条链条目前还没有完整。
但我觉得这条链条可能是下一步。
会慢慢并完整的事。
经营你的各种原因在你离开。
决定离开Authropic NECO。
你对这家公司未来的预期是什么呀？
我觉得我离开的时候。
我对这公司其实挺悲观的。
但后来显然是我过度悲观了。
为什么悲观
我当时悲观的原因是因为。
我当时离开Authropic说了。
Authropic其实。
主要的收入来源都是API。
就是卖图坑
然后
这个差生意
是差生意
因为这个生意
只有对一个公司的好生意。
就是Google。
因为这个生意最后。
就是得打价格战
就是最一般处理就是要打价格战。
打价格战
你没有完整的
这个链条
是没有什么太多优势。
但是后来
Authropic显然在产品方面。
就是我觉得
确实是有很多巧思。
做了很多好的事
管下是考考后的
也变得越来越好用了。
然后考考工作
然后和各种各样的这种。
和工作和效率相关的事情。
都慢慢汇聚起来了。
所以感觉它现在反而变得比。
我当时觉得
你要问我
Open Eye 和Authropic哪个会先死。
但是就不会真的死。
就是哪个会先变得。
没那么重要
我当时会觉得
可能是Authropic会变得。
没那么重要
但是后来首先Open Eye。
被Google揍了一拳。
然后Authropic自己又上道了。
所以现在看来
好像Authropic更占优势一些。
你后悔过没有
不太后悔
我觉得对我个人来说。
我个人的动机
还是想要去换一个地方。
提高自己
我觉得对于这件
对于想做的这件事来说。
这个选择没有什么错误。
对
你也提到Authropic的产品有很多巧思。
特别是今年
就是像Cowork这些。
这个来自于哪里
我觉得我没看到Cowork的发展过程。
所以我不知道
然后ClawCode我觉得。
人
产品
可能还真是
有一些个人英雄主义的机会。
是研究员还是产品质疑。
Boris
就是那个
我觉得ClawCode的几乎。
至少这个事的开端吧？
是他自己想要做这个事。
提高自己或者同事的工作效率。
最后变成了一个
对所有人都有很重要的事。
Boris是一个什么样的人。
我跟他没有太多的个人接触。
我更多的是
看到他的工作在公司的时候。
他是个研究员是吧？
对
但他主要是在产品那边。
所以Authropic是专门产品部门的。
以前没有分的那么开。
后来又有单独的
对Authropic感觉是很懂AI的产品。
对
我觉得
这就是为什么刚开始说的时候。
觉得这个产品经理。
可能还是目前挺难被AI期待的。
好的产品经理
而且他好像不是上一代那种产品经理。
他不是那种
feature的。
百方啊什么的
他好像是
知道怎么跟AI协作的某种产品经理。
对
我觉得
上一代产品经理可能。
但也不全是
上代也有些就是交互方式级别的变化。
但每次交互方式级别变化。
其实就带来一个很大的产品。
比如说就是
可能这个
抖音就是一个交互方式级别改变的产品。
那他一下就带来了很大的。
打开了新的方向
然后我觉得可能
Cloud Code也是一个这样级别的产品。
对了
Cloud Code和Codewalk都是Boris。
我不知道Codewalk是谁做的。
OK
我已经离开了
I see
那说说你到了Google DeepMind以后的工作吧？
工作重新发生变化没有。
还是发生了一些变化的。
然后
我反正我自己
主要在沾外就是做ML Coding。
然后和一些比较老Horizon的事。
就是这两个事其实刚才都大概提了一遍。
就是ML Coding其实它主要就是。
想要实现刚刚说的这个完整的AI自己。
研究自己的这个立场。
那当然这个过程当中。
有很多实际的问题。
也有很多实际的细节要去解决。
就是我觉得大的方向上来说。
大家其实是比较有共识。
是该怎么去做
但是还是回到细节。
就是细节上有很多要处理。
比如说怎么样去选取合适的data。
怎么样去选取合适的回馈信号。
以及它又带来新的计谱设施的挑战。
然后现在就是要把这些事情一样慢慢。
慢慢摸清楚
然后
像老Horizon就是刚才说的另外一点。
就是说想要能够实现说。
这个模型能够在
就还这句口号
true in ways finite。
but use as an infinite。
我觉得想要把训练的长度。
一直一直一直变长。
可能并不是单个训练的。
这个语断的长度一直变长。
可能并不是一个很现实的方案。
但是很现实的事是。
你如何在有限的ConTex下去做更长的工作。
其实你其实是想人其实就是这个样子。
人的ConTex其实很多很短。
你现在问我昨天晚上吃什么？
我是一点想不起来的。
你看人家想起来
因为什么？
因为它对我现在这个场景来说不关键。
对吧？
就是我现在知道昨天晚上吃什么又能怎么样。
所以我选择把它忘掉。
所以人本质上ConTex是很短。
但它能够选择性的遗忘。
然后它选择性的对去retrieve。
就是去把这些重要的跟当今场景相关的信息再抓回来。
所以说我觉得那个可能也是一个对我来说的很有趣的这种方向。
这两件事其实是有点相关有点互补的。
为什么？
就是这两个事其实都在模型使用工具和环境。
以及不同的模型不同的人交互的这个大的范畴内。
在这个范畴内大家就过去完成的那个节点。
就是一瞻这个口点。
就是又是工具又和环境。
环境就是这个虚拟机或者你自己的电脑域。
这个做交互
然后这个事其实它横向就会长出不同的使用场景。
那作为retrieve是其实就是横向这个场景里面。
另外一个场景
而这个场景它其实不仅横向上是一个新场景。
它在纵向上也让这个这个事情的尺度变得更长。
因为你可能完成一个一个代码的补权。
这类是一个很很快的事。
但你做一个完整的AI研究或者做一个。
这种计算机科学的研究那是一个很很长的过程。
对所以说它其实就是像一个T字形一样。
就是横向也有延展然后纵向也有延展。
浪豪的跟是不是还是个科学问题。
有科学问题也有工程问题。
我觉得它科学问题更多的是怎么把不同的方案尝试一下。
以更科学的方式尝试之后来找到一条最后我们要走的这个方案。
这有哪些方式
我可能不太说太细的。
但粗的来说
有一些方案是从pre-train的角度。
从计训来的角度来说。
有一些方案就是类似于这种西出的spark-attention。
这个比如说dpc也有一些工作。
然后学界也有很多工作。
然后从后讯来的角度也有后讯来的方案。
比如说像外界
比如说你每天用什么cursor这些。
他们就是很强的context management。
管理这个context能力。
比如说他可以让这个模型去选择。
哎我把这个中间某一段觉得不重要就扔掉了。
然后那点重要就存在某个文件里头再取回来。
这两种
大得来说
这两种方案
都有人在研究
当然它具体实施细节是不止我刚刚说的这些例子。
刚刚说的这些例子就是比较公开的例子。
具体实施细节当然就没有公司还有自己的小秘密。
我觉得其实也就是最终也都会。
大家都会互相知道。
然后
我个人是比较花很多。
更多时间在后讯来的这部分。
在方案上
因为当然首先因为我自己。
本来就没有花正式的工作时间在预讯链上。
预讯链对我来说更多是一个其实兴趣。
我想学习的事
但我自己其实没有在那上面做太多的工作。
然后另一方面是我觉得。
后讯的这个方案其实更符合我自己对这个事的理解。
我对这个事理解就是刚才一直在说的一件事。
就说能不能用短的context去训练。
但是它能做成context的事。
预讯链的这些方案。
其实本上还是需要你有常常context训练。
它需要数据的有
对对对
所以说
所以它不太符合我对这个问题的哲学。
所以你现在看可以吗？
用短的去训练长的。
我觉得可以是一定可以。
但是我们不清楚哪个方案最有效。
詹曼达的长文本做得很好。
好像为什么呀？
有些技巧
有一些让我很惊讶的技巧。
这是预讯链的事是吧？
长文本做得很好
一定是两边都有的。
但是我只是说对我来说预讯链那边那个技巧。
还是挺让我惊讶的。
对 我们来做的没有专门的好。
在长文本上
但是也有说法也不一样。
有时候有些人也说。
詹曼达三这一代的长文本反而变差了一点这类的。
对
Again 你加入詹曼达的时候。
感觉大家对詹曼达预期不高。
没有 我对詹曼达当时预期已经挺高的了。
你那是几年几月
我是二 就是去年的9月底。
那个是詹曼达放詹曼达三之前。
你对他的预期高
其他人呢？
我觉得业内的人
当时对詹曼达都还是印象不错的吧？
就是我觉得
之前一直觉得Google很有危机。
在OpenL的冲击之下。
我觉得大家的感知可能在。
詹曼达二点五这一代。
产生了变化
因为二点五是一个明显就能看出来。
Google快上到了。
当然之前就是詹曼达的1.5。
也有一些就是
小的事情
某一个去旅途方面做的已经算很强。
就是很明显他已经不是很过后。
但是二点五是真的。
一代我觉得开始有人开始用的模型。
我自己其实也用过二点五。
用的挺多的
你是看到二点五去的詹曼达。
我去詹曼达跟这没关系。
主要还是我知道詹曼达。
他大概是一个什么样的论。
就是有很多人在做不一样的研究。
然后我也知道一些人其实。
做的研究很有意思。
然后很多詹曼达的工程师。
我觉得技术是非常非常非常强的。
我觉得我是从他们身上。
学到了非常非常多。
然后对我来说那是原因。
但是我觉得从大家的感知上来说。
可能我觉得业内的人。
在看到詹曼达2.5之后。
就可能就已经意识到。
我说詹曼达是要赶上来了。
那就你来说是不是你加入了。
詹曼达的一个信号是吧？
不是我加入他的一个信号。
那你为什么加入詹曼达。
那就是刚才说
就是主要是因为我那儿想做事。
其实我想要去有
但你是个詹曼达人强对吧？
对那个是因为
就是他们来找我的时候。
肯定也会让我去和他们的人去聊。
从聊的过程中其实是能看出来。
状态怎么样
是他们来找你的
对但是我觉得最后就变成双相奔赴了。
所以
你当时Opni不是选择吗？
如果你想从DropiGlea制。
对Opni也是当时的选项。
Opni当时应该还是比詹曼达。
从适能上要强吧在那个时候。
不过那个时候是不是。
各种内部的内斗开始出现了。
我觉得
就是Opni确实也是我当时的一个选项。
然后当然还包括像XIA之类的。
然后我觉得Opni最后没有去的一个转业原因。
还是我对他的文化。
至少当时来看
我对他的文化是有比较大的担心的。
就是我觉得
用粗话来说
就是感觉他是做事的人。
没有Jemina多。
也更没有暗消费也多。
这个我很KR
所以一种文化和人的亲近感。
让你去了Jemna。
对
然后你有改善了刀3的那个转折点是吗？
Jemina3应该对他来说是一个。
很大的转折的一个时期是吗？
我觉得从实际的效果来说。
我觉得是两件事让Jemina。
产生了一个大的转折。
就变成了一个市场里举毒区。
听众们的player的玩家是。
Namobonara和Jemina3两件事连着。
就是你我觉得如果只有Jemina3。
可能也不会有现在这么好的效果。
因为当你的市占率连10%都不到的时候。
你这个模型好一点坏一点。
其实等它传播出去就是太慢了。
但是Namobonara做到一件事。
首先市场上这件事很爆。
很爆款
然后大量的人去下载了Jemina的app。
然后Jemina3又紧接着放。
把这个部分留下来了。
所以现在它变成了一个举毒亲手的玩家。
觉得可能就是没有Jemina打这么一拳。
那其实OPI的位置很爽。
觉得市占率已经高到。
你其实模型上干点啥对它来说。
可能影响都没那么大。
甚至说实话我觉得就是真正。
普通人用模型的时候。
对于模型的能力的感知。
其实很弱很弱的
绝大多数人甚至都不用O系列模型。
绝大多数人都用不同的GPC的。
对
所以说我觉得对于Jemina来说。
一个Namobonara把量打下来。
然后Jemina3又把人留下来。
是一个很关键的事。
它有事实上抢走多少拆支BT的用户。
我不知道现在具体的比例。
但是我的感觉是
Jemina可能市占会在20%左右。
但是我确实没有仔细去。
检查过现在的数据。
这是从事后归因来看。
这两个因素共同促成的。
Jemina今天对于OPI的冲击。
但你从内部视角
肯定能更前置的知道。
为什么发生了什么？
Google会有这样的变化。
对 我觉得首先就是。
Google的这个技术储备一直是够的。
人够
对 人一直是够的。
然后组织上来说
就是后来变得越来越清晰。
就是有一个更好的框架来。
让大家一起干这个事。
所以说可能会慢慢有些劲感。
对
然后
有些从某种意义上来说。
我作为一个局外人。
从某种意义上来说。
我觉得OPI还是救了Google一命。
就是
因为大家以前一直都担心说。
这个聊天机器人会不会完全把搜索取代掉。
对
如果这个事真的发生了。
Google其实很难受。
但是好在就是OPI先把这个事做。
然后让Google意识到了这个事很重要。
但是它又没有把这个事做到极致。
又没有完全把搜索干掉。
可能就吃掉了一些份了。
结果让Google自己把聊天机器人也追上来了。
那现在难受就是它了。
你要万一几分有一个公司。
就假如说
在一个虚构世界
有一个公司不仅做了差的Bot。
而且还一路高跟往前越走也好。
真的把你一把就把你搜索吃掉了。
完全没有跟你反击的机会。
那就很难受了
那差棒没有吃掉搜索。
是因为OPI干得不好。
还是为什么呢？
还是因为这个形态干不掉搜索。
我觉得两方面其实都有。
就是说首先目前的差别报仇交互方式。
其实不会完全吃掉搜索。
因为它比搜索的强。
就像刚刚最早说过。
它比搜索的强的一点是说。
它有很强的交互性。
你可以追问
然后你可以把
它可以帮你把一些很复杂的信息去浓缩。
这是很强的地方
所以这部分使用场景。
它确实会把搜索的人抢掉。
但是搜索里还有一些非常愚蠢的场景。
就是你有一个特别简单的事。
你根本不想浪费这个时间在聊天机。
比如说我就搜买大米。
我就一搜买就完了。
我还非得去问XGDP。
我还得问哪个好
然后他还在那转向这转半天。
然后给你一个零元件再一点。
再跑到网也再去买。
没有那个必要
所以说从事实的使用上来说。
它目前的形态并不足以把搜索完全吃掉。
然后当然从那个角度上来说。
它可能在聊天机前这个时间。
也没有做到灯风造急。
就它还真的让Google给感扬吧？
现在还不算赶上吧？
在产品上
我觉得在产品上不算赶上。
但是在模型上已经是赶上了。
但是要投资人投OpenAI。
他们会说
他们下注的时候是认清楚。
OpenAI其实是一个产品公司的时候。
它的互衬盒其实是产品和品牌。
那从今天来看的话。
似乎Google还没有在这件事情上能够。
不能是超越OpenAI吧？
赶上OpenAI吧？
对 就是我觉得
这其实是
反正这都是我作为一个局外人。
观察者的视角来说。
你今天是点评家
观察者的角度来说。
我觉得Google传统上在产品。
就是有点慢
是一直都不讲慢
所以你说
OpenAI会不会在产品上有优势。
我觉得是有可能的。
对
然后
Google特别擅长的一件事是什么？
是找到一个
具为简单的产品心态。
大家都长一个样
它就疯狂给你卷技术。
你就卷不过它
对
我觉得那个事是Google擅长的。
因为搜索引擎就是这样的一个事。
搜索就是这个典型。
就是大家都是一个框。
一个键
但它就是比你搜得快。
搜得比你准
你拿来一点办法也没有。
所以这为什么就是。
我感觉就是一直以来。
Google都处于一个。
做得很好
华尔街都不太认可的状态。
大家总觉得
这公司比例到底在哪。
也没有什么产品的巧思。
也没有是刘恒的机制。
但他就活到了现在。
所以他技术好的原因是什么？
就人好吗？
我觉得还是氛围吧？
就是说是一个特别重视。
以前就特别重视
工程师后来就是特别重视。
研究的这样一个氛围。
所以他很适合那种。
通过技术能力
一出的产品能力的产品。
如果从这个角度来看的话。
那你觉得OpenEye的位置。
是稳固的吗现在
我觉得像谁的位置都不稳固。
我觉得就是
AI的形态还有很长的路要走。
没有到什么终局之战。
这个地方的感觉呢？
感觉国内已经有点这意思了。
对我不理解
为什么不理解
我很费劫
国内觉得我们在争夺一个super app。
super app就是此消彼长的。
我觉得condition on聊天机器人。
这个事就是super app。
那可能可以争夺一下。
但是问题是
你这个形态是不是super app的形态。
会不会别人就是哪天出了一个。
完全不一样的形态。
然后你的功能
变成那个东西的一个字极。
这是很有可能的是吗？
我觉得没有什么？
我觉得我看不出什么不可能。
为啥插报
为啥插报不是那个终极形态。
但是这么多年我们也就看到这个了。
对就是
都是一个对话抗
我觉得在这个事上我确实没有什么？
没有什么理性或者量化的标准来说明。
更多的是
你觉得这个事很蠢。
就是这个模型明明有那么多的能力。
但居然用的方法是插的bought。
就是不太make sense。
所以需要一个产品经理来解放一下模型的能力。
人类到现在只通过插报去跟AI沟通。
让你觉得很蠢是吧？
很蠢
就是
那应该用什么去跟AI沟通。
没想明白
要想明白我就干了。
你没有告诉我Google内部到底发生了什么变化。
然后有了外界看到的和模型能力的突废猛进。
对
就是刚才说一个
我觉得组织上干清楚了。
然后组织上一旦清楚的话。
组织变化了吗？
对
尤其像预训来现在变得非常非常清楚。
就是谁负责什么事情。
然后每一个点
每一个节点上谁是负责人。
这些事情都很清楚。
以前是混沌的吗？
以前啊？
这早时候很乱
我没有最早时候在那待过。
但是就是同事
根据同事或者我以前认识的人的描述。
以前还是更混乱一些的。
对
然后现在就是
稍运运运来也是变得非常非常清楚。
然后加上
这个Google一直有的这种。
就是比较强的技术背景。
然后它的做事比较系统。
所以我觉得预训连在Google是一个非常非常可控的事。
可预测的事
你能够
你能够知道下一代。
不会查
然后可能你还会知道它会有多好。
对
通过Dropik这种自上而下的管理。
它也
不错
那Google是这种自下而上的。
它依然是自下而上的什么？
它比以前肯定要更自上而下了。
比起最早的时候
但是它比
朝北来说还是更自下而上了一些。
就是好像不同的文化都可以是吗？
对
模型的勋改
就是我觉得大公司有大公司的打算。
Starshot有Starshot的打算。
所以大公司是
你刚才也说它是一个完全不一样的趋势。
它是一个不一样的方法。
Google是什么方法现在。
我觉得Google更多的说是像这种比较确定性的事。
比如像预训连已经是一个比较确定性的范氏了。
那可能Google就会。
更像把它做成一个工程项目。
Google的工程管理能力很强。
所以说它就能慢慢地把它做好。
什么叫工程项目
工程项目的意思就是。
你其实是非常非常非常逃不到的一个组织。
然后很清楚我们下一阶段要做的是什么事情。
然后去做这个事情中间需要有哪几个节点被处理掉。
然后哪怕是做研究也是说。
就是有一个很清晰的空间。
告诉你怎么去验证你的结果是好是坏。
以价值的你结果是好是坏。
对
其实这个是Google很强的事情。
在过去的任何的一个大的工程项目上。
所以说预训连其实我觉得就是现在进入到Google的舒适区里了。
然后后续连当然就是有更多的不确定性。
那可能后续连现在说还是更Bottom up一点。
就是大家可以跟我广泛的事。
对
你说Prince川你也是一种RL。
为什么这么说
我觉得就是你很难从纯技术的角度说。
匪讯连和或者说这个监督学习SFT和RL的本质区别是什么？
因为预训连和SFT。
当然预训连和SFT本质也没啥区别。
就是你无非就是把你拿到的那些数据当成你的光Truth。
然后你就把那个当成你的Expert。
把那个当成你的专家输出。
然后你朝那个专家输出的分布上靠。
强化学习可能就是更宽广的一个级别。
一个级
他就是说我
首先就是这个本质输出的东西。
也不是一个给定的专家。
是我自己产生的一些东西。
然后我里面有好的结果。
有不好的结果
然后我好的结果
我往上靠不好的结果。
要演绎它之类的这样东西。
所以说从伯仲宁上来说。
匪讯连和SFT是强化学习一个字。
但是呢？
这两件事确实在现在这个时代是有区别。
他我觉得对我来说。
他的最大区别在数据上。
就是普春宁的数据。
更多的还是要Disputing口号。
就是分布足够的广。
或者足够符合你想要。
覆盖出的那些范围。
但是数据的质量
并不需要非常非常高。
但是后续来就反过来。
就说他分布上来说。
可能要远窄
但是他在有的那些数据。
质量上回要求非常高。
所以我觉得目前来说。
对我来说他俩最本质区别。
还是在数据分布上的区别。
不是在算法或者训练范图上的区别。
那像不同的lab。
他是怎么分这组的。
与训练和后训练
有不同吗？
还是都一样
SRP和Google比较类似。
两个都是就是
与训练是与训练一个组。
然后后训练是后训练一个组。
OPPA可能比较混沌。
最早的时候
一开始的时候他是分三个组。
他有预训练
然后他还有
强化学习
就是Strawberry草莓组。
然后他还有一个Pose Training组。
然后我没在那干过。
但我的理解是他的Pose Training。
其实是
就不是
他的RL组就是Strawberry和他的Pose Training。
其实是别的公司的Pose Training和产品。
然后他可能是以一种不一样的方式给他切了。
他把后训练当产品做。
就是他的一部分后训练。
其实是还产品
是在做产品
他是不是名字没改过来呢？
完全是
因为绝大多数公司的产品。
其实不太训练模型了。
他更多的是把这个需要的。
这个模型特质
告诉训练模型的团队。
但是他好像就是他的Pose Training。
从模型上说自己又是产品。
但自己又能训练模型。
这是不是他对于产品的理解。
就是需要训练模型的人来做产品。
对对对
有可能
有可能是一件好事。
对
但是他后来也这个组织变化很多次。
我现在也不知道他们组织成啥样。
你们最近发挥几个模型。
然后我看到你也都参与其中。
Gemna3 DeepThink。
Gemna3.1 Pro。
我觉得可能
只能说是有幸参与。
感觉就是感觉都是集体工作。
你为什么现在都变成明星人物。
然后每次都被拎出来单独写一下。
我不明白
我觉得其实不太好。
每次看到之后我都感觉。
明天该怎么去办公室见同事呢？
会有意样吗？
在办公室
这还好
我觉得同事可能
可能还是人比较好。
就是他们可能也不是特别看重这些事。
但说实话我是觉得。
我参与过的任何一个项目。
不管是在Google还是在。
没有我都会罚上
都一样会罚上
效果也不会变差
我觉得大家现在就是每个人都是冲浪的人。
本质上是一个浪
而不是你那个冲浪的人。
浪是AI吗？
对
就是AI这个事情本身是这个浪。
它会往前走
不管你冲不冲这个浪。
这个浪都会拍到爱上。
只是说有人可能就冲了这个浪。
有人就可能晚了一点。
没改上那个浪尖
好
你有心地参与了这两个工作的什么？
主要可能就是有一些。
算法上设计的小的细节。
然后又会一块讨论。
然后有一些数据上的东西。
但是数据上的东西。
我觉得可能对之后的工作。
会影响更大一些
这几个模型有方式变化吗？
我觉得没有哪个变化。
大到从不知道怎么做。
大石头强化学写那个级别的变化。
没有哪个变化大到这个地步。
肯定都是会有一些小小的变化。
这几个小小变化你们讲一讲。
这几个新的模型
不能讲
好
很不幸对不起
最近我感觉模型已经发麻了。
国内一堆模型
国外也是很多模型。
L.O.P.I.你们。
国内JLM自己
Dipstick一直期待还没发。
Kimi
你能不能给大家画画重点。
我觉得
从模型上来说都没那么值得关注。
大家在争什么现在。
感觉群魔乱斗
我觉得有一些争的事情。
其实现在看来
现在在这个时代已经没那么重要了。
就是因为过去带来的惯性。
是大家会争各个Banchmark的第一名。
证明自己模型的基本能力很强。
这个事情其实到现在已经到了。
就是公众关注的那些Banchmark。
都有点打满了
就是你想最早大家关注。
这个SuiBanch。
SuiBanch大家都打了80多。
幸亏没有人超过83。
因为最近O.P.I.刚放一个姿势。
说超过83那个有的题目。
都是不良好定义的。
幸亏没人超过
谁超过是谁能干啊反正。
然后
大家以前
打完Ami
打AMO
打完AMO
打什么？
想不想2KGI
这些Banchmark。
然后RKGI
我们在Gemma3之前。
大家可能最高的都。
往那时候可能10G这样子吧？
然后大家就往灯天南。
然后Gemma3给变成30多。
然后Cloud
7.5还是4.6变成60多。
然后Gemma3。
Deep Sync一下打到80多。
所以这个也打嘛？
所以现在就是感觉。
光靠
打这种公众认知的模型能力。
其实已经
没啥太大的意思了。
然后
所以从这个角度来说。
其实本身上就是没有什么太多的种变。
虽然大家发得很快。
发得快也说明
其实这道题对大家所有人来说都变简单了。
在都知道弄好了
没有什么秘密了一件。
对
就是还是说
还是这个
就还是那个
冲浪理论
也还是这个浪在往前走。
大家下一个可能在寻找的目标是什么？
下一个范氏级的变化是什么？
还会有吗？
我觉得我刚才自己聊的那两个事。
是我觉得ML Coding和Langhorizon。
对
然后这两个是我觉得。
我觉得
是我觉得是一个
可能没有到范氏级变化。
但是我觉得是
对于Google来说会很有价值的事情。
因为首先
ML Coding是因为Google首先。
自己是一个AI Reset大户。
然后它自己又是AI Reset是最全站的。
就是它不仅有这些。
训练模型这些这些部分。
它还有涉及硬件的部分。
从硬件接到模型的部分。
这一整套东西如果能被加速会。
或者说被更好的管理。
那可能对这个公司来说是很有价值。
Langhorizon就不说了。
所以所有人都知道。
就所有人都觉得很重要。
对
所以说我觉得那个可能是对我来说。
不能说是范氏级变。
绝对是不到范氏级变。
但是是一个我觉得是很有价值。
需要去在未来几个月之内。
能够看到曙光的事。
然后
我觉得范氏级可能就还是那些。
更非确定性的东西。
就是什么动漫台山城。
那个我觉得
可能会有一个英雄吧？
或者会有一个英雄集体吧？
然后对
像那种可能会有一些。
还有聊比较多的continual learning。
世界模型呢？
我觉得continual learning和这种Langhorizon。
刚刚说Langhorizon没有本质的区别。
因为
因为大家以前觉得这两事差别很大。
是因为continual learning会改变模型的一些权重。
然后你做这种
比如像开放开源的。
大家做很多这种contest management。
是不会改变模型权重的。
但其实你想这两事没有本质区别。
因为contest里那些。
词自己的kbp也是一种权重。
所以说你觉得这两方案就是。
最后谁能更有用
在长久来说更就更有用。
我觉得是不清楚的。
但是他们本质上都是为了。
做刚才Langhorizon这种类型的事情。
然后世界模型
1万个人又1万个世界模型。
啥意思
就是定义不清醒
就是首先我不知道什么叫做一个世界模型。
其实就是每个人
在说他们做的世界模型的时候。
可能也在说不一样的事。
比如说咱们俩做的世界模型课呢？
就和比如像想飞飞。
李飞飞他们做的世界模型。
就不是一个事
描述一下区别是
我不是特别了解
像外面像李飞飞他们这些lab做的事情。
到底是怎么样呢？
但是咱们来的世界模型。
更多的是一种
是种antwend的这种级别训练。
他想要的结果是说。
比如说视频生成的是。
大家能够给定一个描述。
然后生成一个视频。
但他想要的结果是。
我不仅能够生成一个视频。
我是能够生成一个场景。
什么叫一个场景
场景就是说我生成了这个。
这个时刻的状态
然后我还可以再给他一个condition。
一个条件
这个条件是我在放他一下。
做了一样什么样的什么动作。
然后他下一个时刻状态。
会变成我上一个时刻状态和动作的函数。
然后他是antwend去训练这样的能力。
所以说这个可能是一种方案。
然后我首先也不知道。
大家最后想要的到底是什么结果。
然后我也不知道
大家对自己世界模型的定义。
到底是什么？
所以我觉得更多还是一种探索的状态。
刚才我们一直没有聊到一个组织社XAI。
我们刚才聊了anthropic。
聊了open eye。
聊了divide。
XAI呢？
XAI我是要不明白。
作为电瓶加班书
他们怎么最近这么动荡。
我觉得他们一直都挺动荡。
但为什么最近这么动荡。
我也不知道
然后我其实我跟XAI接触的没有那么多。
然后我接触的一些人现在也走了。
所以我也不知道他们发生了啥。
对了
刚才说anthropic的时候。
你说技术的一号位能能被MacBath是非常重要的。
那在Google这样的一号位是谁。
这个英雄是谁
我觉得英雄可能在不同的阶段也是不一样的人。
但英雄的背后都有一个人。
就是Serge
就是Google那个口方的。
对对对
其实我觉得最终很多大的决定。
可能不是由他来决定怎么做。
但是最后拍那个版本得他来拍。
现在也是
Diamonds呢？
我觉得可能更多的在一线出现的是Corey。
对
就是D-CPU
然后他现在也是Google的SVP。
Diamonds在负责什么？
我觉得Diamonds可能管了更多那种就是偏Science的事情。
就比如说那个药物的design isomorphic lab那些事情。
对对对
Diamond呢他管的不多。
这样从我的视角来说。
我看到的更多的是Corey。
OK
但是有可能就是那公司那个管理层的事。
其实也有可能很多是我看不到的部分。
那我就不清楚
你刚才提到AS怎么是一个系统吗？
你对于怎么系统性的做AI有什么？
认知吗现在
经过了你这两年的工作。
有几方面吧？
一方面是从整个系统来说。
它需要一种比较科学的态度。
就是你要清楚的
像Scanner就是你要清楚的理解自己做了什么样的预设。
然后我在做一个改变的时候。
其实有哪些因素是他相关联的。
哪些因素是不相关联的。
然后这是从组织情况下来说。
从人的情况下说
其实需要人很reliable。
就是需要很负责任的人。
其实每一个系统
就每一个品牌的方向都是很容易被hacked的。
因为你总可以做一些事。
让你的指标看起来很好看。
但是一个值得信赖或者踏实的人。
他其实是会想自己做的这件事如果效果好的话。
是不是真的比如在大的手中效果好。
是不是我中间露的那些因素。
所以说其实把事做系统听起来是一句话。
但真正做起来是很复杂的事。
就是有很多细节
有很多阻力会
因为它其实违背人性。
因为每个人个人的人性可能都是为了让我自己做的东西能够提前得更好。
但是对一个公司或者一个组织来说最有利的事。
是把整个公司的系统性做得非常扎实。
非常严谨
这个能闻局建例子好像有点抽象。
对 它确实有点抽象。
所以这也是你说没有那么多的个人英雄主义的一个表现。
人要变成一个更可信可靠的系统的组建。
我可以举一个可能也是比较诡判的例子。
就是比如说做乔海学习。
你可能可以做一个算法出来效果比别人好。
但是可能最更关键的问题是。
你要去问比如说在真正的大的使务下。
我是不是能够保持稳定性是一样好的。
然后以及我比别人的东西效果好。
是不是因为我用了不一样的data。
以及我是不是用了更多的training的flop。
是不用了更多的sampling的flop。
然后我具体在真的这个生产的这个最后这个大的跑。
跑的这个properation run里面。
到底哪一个才是我的限制因素。
然后我该开讯了一个指标。
这个些可能都是需要连续原自己对于这个系统。
怎么运作有一个好的理解。
然后以及对公司负责人才能做到。
否则就是你很容易做到一件事。
就是你可能比如说你在考虑trainin的时候是比别人好的。
但你考虑trainin加三分的时候比别人差了。
你总可以选择你指数trainin。
但这就很很糟糕
所以这个就是继续要你个人的负责人。
负责人又需要说组织所建立的这个体系里能够。
能尽量的发现这些有意的或者不意的这种边界的事情。
但是你作为个体的话。
你不知道怎么样是对全局最好的呀？
其实是需要
我觉得如果一个研究员做不到对全局去考虑的话。
这就不是考的研究员。
在现在这个时代
就是这个核
我觉得这个核
你就是在学术界做的瑞色是很不一样的事。
因为在学术界做瑞色是本质上是。
一根吃饱全家不愁的状态。
就是我为我的项目负责对吧？
我为我的可从负责。
但是在一个公司里你其实更多的时候是。
我得为这个公司的负责。
对这是两种完全不一样的心态。
那你这种自觉性从哪儿来的。
不知道
我觉得我可能就是。
拉拨下脸
对对对一个公司付的认识。
你和这个公司的契约的一部分。
其实我觉得没什么道理不这么做。
这么做是没有原因的。
所以个人英雄主义会破坏这种整体性。
我觉得如果只是为了跟人英雄主义而做事的话。
很有可能是会破坏整体性的。
当然实际可能你能力很强。
然后你真的成了一个英雄。
那也是有可能
因为你也经历了两个组织了。
你觉得什么样的组织更能够激发智能。
在这个时代
我觉得其实这是一个很。
很有争议的事
就是说
因为刚才也聊了
就是不同组织可能有些比较自上而下。
有些比较自下而上。
一个自然问题说
比如说这两种组织哪个更能够激发创新。
过去的观点就是自下而上是激发创新。
比较条件
因为就是你得每个人有自由。
自由才能有创新
但是完全自下而上去。
发现其实也不行
因为它就乱
它就是Google之前的样子是吗？
对 至少在我印象里。
就是在我了解到的印象里是这样。
就是它就乱
就是大家甚至都不知道我做这个事有什么用。
那可能也不好
所以就可能要需要有一个人。
或者有一个小的集体。
能够把这两件事稍微融合一些。
对
就是为什么我觉得。
其实这个一个组织运行得好不好。
看起来是组织的问题。
但其实
归根结底是技术领导的问题。
就是这个技术领导有没有特质。
能够把这个组织运行得很稳定。
因为最好的那个状态。
往往都是最不稳定的状态。
就很容易往不好的那个方向塌缩的。
对
所以得有一个领导来控制这些事。
那你觉得都是技术领导来做这个事情。
而不是CEO来做这个事情。
当然美公司的CEO可能有不一样的职责。
但是得有一个领导。
我觉得只要得有一个领导。
他能有两个特质才能去做这个事。
一个特质就是说
他自己有救火的能力。
不是说他光嘴上说要做什么？
要做什么？
而说有一件事真的遇到困难了。
他能自己下场去带人把这个困难解决掉。
当然绝大动数时候。
可能一个领导是不会有时间去做这个事。
但他至少有这个能力。
有第二个重要特质就是。
他得能够理解别人。
就哪怕一件事可能是他不做的事。
但他能够理解到为什么别人做那个事重要。
能够容不下别人
那可能是另外一个特质。
你觉得Google的TPU。
在哪些方面表现得比GPU更好。
劣势是什么？
我觉得从纯硬件的角度来说。
很难说哪种硬件真的好或者坏。
尤其是在一种大规模商用的情况下。
因为本质上来说
GPU和TPU
在使用上来说
最大的区别就跑到硬件的区别来说。
使用上来说最大的区别就是。
GPU它有比较好的开源生态。
GPU没有
但这个事其实在大规模商用的时候。
并不是一个问题
因为比如Google自己用TPU。
那自然会花时间去搭这个GPU设施。
而GPU设施就是一个。
比如说你只跑一前掌卡。
那可能是一个很大的负担。
但你跑一个几十万掌卡的集群。
搭一个GPU设施。
也不是一个多大事。
然后从实际上这种大规模商用。
来说没有哪个熟悠熟练。
但是这两个确实有一些设计理念上的区别。
比如说GPU至少。
我可能后来这几代GPU没这么用过。
比如像Hopper那代GPU。
H系列GPU
它的设计是说
我一个炮子里面可能没有多少张卡。
比如说就八张卡
然后这八张卡之间。
可以两辆互联NVLink非常快。
所以这一个炮子几乎就是没有什么？
communication的Bound。
但GPU它可能就反过来。
它就是说我抛弃了卡之间两辆互联。
但是我能尽量的把尽量多的卡。
放在一个大的架子里面。
它就是有这种三维Taurus的设计。
所以它就一张卡
这只有在三个方向连三个最精灵的。
但它整个集群可以连成一个大Taurus。
然后如果你的Compiler。
或者你的Sharding的逻辑写得足够好的话。
你是可以利用这样的东西。
其实就等下来说
你会获得更大的储存空间。
然后也会减少很多封信的Bound。
对
劣势是什么？
我觉得一个劣势就是。
它肯定是比起GPU来说。
至少在小的Scale上来说。
比起GPU是更加固定的一种结构。
虽说它的应用性或者它的通用性可能没有那么强。
对
最近硅谷有很多New Lab出现。
你怎么看这个趋势。
为什么他们都出去。
从这些模型大厂跳出去成立New Lab。
我看不太懂
我的感觉是绝大多数New Lab都会死。
我觉得有一些Labs是真的有好的人。
像有些Labs可能也开始在做一些事。
比如说像Sinkin Machine。
它还是在deliver一些新的东西的。
然后但有些New Lab就是。
请帮我把名字低调。
好
比如说
我就完全不知道他们到底要干嘛？
然后这俩人其实也远离这个专业好久了。
我觉得26年国内会非常的看重C端的叙事。
谁成为Super App。
你怎么看
你觉得这个正好像在规模没有人讲这个事。
对
因为美国Enterprise就是这个公司或者说效率软件。
这个市场太大
而且利润也太高
所以说对于美国来说。
其实C端之前就只有差了GP一家座。
其实也没啥油水
没有什么利润
所以说现在大家可能重心都会先放在这种效率软件或者Enterprise。
所以中美的趋势已经发生差异化了。
我觉得不只是AI。
就是过去的互联都不一样。
就是中国很强的就是C端。
就是它能够想出一些非常非常复杂的产品的性质或者结构。
然后用一种很
你觉得很间接很不自然的方式把这个利润滚下来。
比如说什么叫很间接。
就比如说像抖音这种东西。
它并不是说你看视频。
我看一个视频收你两毛钱对吧？
还是说你可以免费看视频。
但是我可以偷偷加广告。
我可以偷偷做直播。
我可以偷偷做电商。
但是这个做效率软件没这事。
做效率软件非常直接。
就是我让你帮你写code的。
我成本一个月150卖你250卖。
就是非常直接的事。
我觉得美国在过去的体现。
就是在这种很直接的产品上。
能够把技术做到极致。
但是一直没有哪个产品。
然后我觉得就是复杂到说。
让你离不开它
你有感觉不到它在挣你的钱。
但它实际上挣了你的钱。
你这么说我突然觉得mata就应该抄自己的做。
对 但我觉得mata没自己强。
因为mata它也找不到自己的生态位。
然后美国又没有一个做这件事情的公司。
就是豆包这个生态位还没有人找到。
mata就抄豆包呗。
它也不需要那么强的模型能力。
对 但我觉得还是美国做产品的。
本质上做C端产品的人不行。
比中国来说差远了。
这是过去实验的极猎是吗？
对
因为过去10年在美国的正反馈。
都来自于做2B的很多。
或者就是在美国这种挣钱太容易。
挣钱太容易的时候你不会废脑筋去想怎么挣钱。
不是很多人来都要找你聊聊吗？
有什么好玩的人
还有很多国内的人来科技公司来。
对 我觉得都挺好玩的。
然后确实发现国内的人做产品可能还是。
想法更复杂一些
更复杂一些
对 就是想的这个回路更长一些。
跟美国还是风格不太一样。
美国是
美国就刚才说了
我就是做个什么就拿这个卖钱了。
对 就是简单
就是这个事就是需要这个能力。
有了一个能力之后。
就是要比别人便宜。
我就能挣得迷你多。
拿有一点办法也没有。
中国呢？
中国感觉都是这种什么一开始不挣钱。
但一旦它开始挣钱你就拦不住它。
就是它是真的能形成自己的那个圈的。
你就是它真的把那个圈转起来的时候。
你再往里插就插不进去了。
你觉得美国公司现在看得懂自己跳动没有。
我的感觉是没有
还没有
它都这么大了
你说是不是重视啥。
那肯定是重视的
大家肯定都知道自己是一家被严重低估。
从它的市值上来说是被严重低估的公司。
这是我觉得大家很明确的事。
然后我觉得也很明确就是说在消费者市场这一端。
其实我觉得没有哪个公司能和自己竞争。
但是它毕竟是在中国公司。
至少从公众的公众意识上来说。
它毕竟是在中国公司。
你自己看懂它了吗？
我不觉得大家看懂它。
但是你看Mata。
其实也在主动的从自己挖人。
你在AI行业有什么偶像吗？
或者欣赏的人
虽然你在AI行业很短。
没啥
就是我感觉
我感觉我来这行业的时候。
跟英雄主义时代已经过去了。
所以也没有什么英雄。
有时候你甚至觉得就时代英雄有点蠢。
对 所以说真的没有什么？
你觉得谁比较蠢
这个还是不说了
No comment。
对 我觉得和作物理说还是不一样。
我觉得作物理说还是存在这些。
我觉得真的比我聪明太多的人。
比如我读博的时候。
我那个年轻老板
我觉得他Douglas Stanford。
我觉得他就比我聪明太多了。
我觉得他
可能也是看到他
我才觉得自己待在那个领域也没什么用。
有他了还要我干嘛呢 对吧？
得跑到AI来较为打击一下是吧？
也没较为打击
但是反正就感觉AI这个事。
本来也不太需要脑子。
不太需要脑子
真的不太需要脑子。
需要什么？
我觉得这个行业最重要的特质。
就是靠谱
就是做事 细
然后对自己做的事负责任。
这是最重要的特质。
你说那些东西有多需要脑子。
我觉得都是一些本科生就能干的活。
可是你说AI没有个人英雄主义。
现在一个AI研究员的价格炒得多高。
跟球星转会一样
我不知道是好事还是坏事。
对我个人来说我大人很高兴。
我受益于这个对吧？
但是实际上来说
我并不知道这个事是不是。
是不是一件好事
你觉得为什么价格会变得这么高。
我觉得可能一方面是。
大家觉得这个事很稀缺。
但是它实际上可能确实也没那么充足。
就是因为训练一个人。
虽然这个事没那么难。
但是你训练一个人是需要一个环境的。
就是你得有那个机会去接触这件事。
你才能学会这件事。
你没有那个机会你就是再聪明也没用。
那可能过去能撞到这个机会的人。
没有那么多
所以说在试条来说。
可能是比较吸血
从这个角度上来说。
但我觉得另一方面也是。
可能对人的炒作有点过分了。
对
非常喜欢神话个体现在。
对 我觉得真的
那
就是再说一次
这是个集体主义的事。
那很多人也会很好奇。
因为可能很多公司也想招AI的人。
那你觉得最重要的还是要靠谱。
这个有什么衡量指标呢？
就是怎么能够快速地。
判断一个人靠谱
做实习不写
每个人都有一些自己。
衡量的方法
然后我当然也有一些自己的trick。
我以前好像有出一道面试题。
然后那个
我会大概讲一下这个。
这个应该不是个迷思。
我也更加可以讲
那面试题其实很简单。
就是说
我需要这个人在24小时之内。
然后完成一个强化学习的项目。
从0到1
就是他要自己去选。
用什么样的模型
我告诉他他有的资源是什么样的。
然后他就去选用什么样的模型。
用什么样的数据
用什么样的算法
然后把这个模型迅出来。
24小时之内
就是我给他
让他24小时去完成这个事。
然后24小时结束之后。
他会跟我有一个小时的讨论。
然后这个事呢？
其实在AI时代没有那么难。
没有AI的时候这是不可能的。
没有人从24小时之内把它做出来。
但有AI之后其实特别简单。
因为AI能把你全套做。
但为什么还要做这个事呢？
有两个原因
我有很多原因
其中设计成这样的两个原因。
一个原因是因为
我觉得在这个时代。
还去考察别人
比如说代码写的好不好。
其实没用
因为绝大多数人都不用自己写代码。
然后他更重要的是。
他能不能有效地利用AI。
那这个事一个方面的考察这个问题。
第二方面是这个事其实有一个陷阱。
就是如果你全盘上AI做了。
但你最后没有试图好好理解AI。
为你做了什么？
那在那一个小时的讨论里面会露相。
那是一个
那个是一个会挂人的地方。
对
所以说那个考验的另一件事。
就是说你有没有真的和AI形成的写作。
还是说你就全权扔给他。
那个是我
我觉得我个人看中了事。
那个其实也是他
就是这个人是不是左手抛谱的一部分。
当然这个题目的设计本身也有一些。
一些比较阴暗的巧思。
就是说为什么设计成24小时。
就是为了看这个人。
就多看着这个机会。
跟他熬夜
对
如果他足够熬夜
他就能撑住这24个小时。
如果他撑不住
那只能说他可能对这个机会也没有那么看中。
那对于比你更年轻的人。
你觉得他们现在来AI还是一个很。
很狼害
就是很有机会的地方吗？
我觉得
纯作语言模型已经不是一个狼害了。
嗯
我觉得晚了
就是木板车已经发车了。
木板车已经发车
木板那边是哪一班。
我感觉我入行的就是那个木板车。
然后
可能有确实在我入行之后。
当然还有一些新的人。
但我觉得他们就没有机会。
能接受那么好的机会。
就是能在一个还没那么小。
没那么大的团体里做一件事情。
那么可能就很少能遇到这样的机会了。
对
然后
但是我觉得AI它是一个很大的方向。
语言模型只是其中的很小。
很小一个部分
还有很多别的事情。
比如刚刚说的多么太生成。
那可能还有很多机会。
机器人那可能更机会更多。
然后
包括更夸张的就是。
比如说
你能不能用AI去帮助一些真正的科学问题。
帮助做量子调控之类的。
那可能就是更蓝海。
那都是blue sky的事了。
对
所以说
我觉得对于足够年轻的人来说。
可能做现在最热火的事。
并不是一个正确的选择。
做现在没有人做到的事。
可能更多的是一个好的选择。
对
你自己未来会怎么发展。
你会在谷歌很久吗？
我觉得应该不会
这么公开的说法
好
我觉得应该不会
我觉得我还是会尝试。
去挑战自己的
然后
要折磨自己
对
但是我就是可能需要找到一个值得。
折磨我自己的事
如果不是本质的难的话。
你会不会觉得无聊啊？
你对你的挑战在哪啊？
我觉得
它虽然不难
但是你知道和不知道。
还是有一个gap的。
就是你从完全
不知道这个其中的细节。
到慢慢理解这个其中的细节。
理解它怎么运作的之类的。
这些事情我觉得还是。
需要花时间花力气的。
然后当你理解之后。
我觉得对这个事
也是会对你未来做。
比如不管你是做产品相关。
还是说往别的A2的方向去发展。
我觉得都是长期来说会有帮助的。
你未来想在哪里去盘上。
我觉得都是可能
没想好该怎么折磨自己。
你应该不会再跳去另外一个。
大公司了吧？
你应该不太会了
你觉得你在DrawPick上学的。
和在Google Demand学的有什么不一样。
我觉得还是挺不一样。
我觉得在想DrawPick。
就是你可以把一个事。
了解很
摆一条线
就是Langui的Model这条线。
得方方面面的了解得很透。
它给你这样的机会。
然后在Google它更多的是一种横向。
就是它有很多不同的方面。
还有很多不一样的人。
然后你能见到不一样的视角。
也能见到不一样的研究方向。
就是你都可以看见。
DrawPick是因为它Bat的足够的坚定。
所以你能理解得更纵向。
你有想过用AI去解决物理问题吗？
你们那个评论物理。
有人在干
所以我觉得不需要我去干。
你对这个没有本质的信尺。
我觉得这个事就是。
首先我觉得目前对我来说。
不是最高优先级
我觉得如果哪天
我觉得我把我手上。
最高优先级的事解决了。
我又没有找到别的事干。
我可能会去干这个事。
你现在最高优先级是什么？
我现在最高优先级是。
就是把我刚才说的这两个事情。
能够
还没有Coding和Langue Horizon。
把它至少推进到一个。
就是合同是能够把它推进到一个。
比较
我觉得比较较稳定的状态。
那个我觉得是我的最高Friority。
但是可能之后也会有。
别的Friority。
但是自用外赖做物理。
我觉得是一个
已经有很多人在试。
这做的事
然后多一个
不多少一个我不少。
不如就让别人先干。
你有特别崇拜的物理学家吗？
也没有
有
但是有点多
不知从何说起
物理学家有
人工智能科学家没有。
但这个跟人的成长经历有关吧？
就我觉得就是
一个成年人是很难真的崇拜一个人的。
一个儿童可能会
崇拜过谁啊？
我觉得就物理学家。
其实还有很多
就真的挺
挺强的
但是就是大家都说的那种。
是不是100年前那种人就不说了。
就什么？
什么Aston
古老这种
体系的时候
其实有一个
他后来也难过讲
就是那个好战
就是你会发现这些人他。
他
有些异常的远见
就是他在他那个时代显得格格不入。
但是
你看好战最开始做。
好战model和这些。
分数量的后来相关的事的时候。
离最后大家搞明白这些透枯物态。
过了好几十年
在那个时候
他能够觉得这事重要。
一直在自己在推进这事。
我觉得这是一个很不容易的。
当然我觉得你要在人工智能找一个类似的人。
我觉得可能Jeffrey England是吧？
就是在大家都觉得这事。
可有可无或者
不那么确定的时候。
他一直在这个方向做。
那我觉得这可能是一个英雄级别的人物。
在他之后呢？
AMAM在他之后我觉得。
我觉得可能
也有一些英雄的集体。
就是比如像Transformer。
就是Normosa Jair和那些。
RCHR
Nikki England。
那可能是一个英雄集体。
你讲过的一个特别。
让我印象很深的话。
我在这个行业又没有什么道士。
又没有什么旧有
我小喷水喷水
这可能就是不做AI的好处。
不做AI出身的好处。
对
真的没有什么负担。
就是
没有哪个老的
可能是你的亲属
所以你觉得他傻
他就是傻
就可以直接说他傻。
无所谓的
你以前也这样吗？
我觉得我做学生的时候。
还挺收敛的
但我后来发现
收敛
没用
对自己也没好处
对别人也没好处
还是
更直接的表达自己的想法。
是最关键
我觉得直接表达自己的想法。
是一个
短期一定会有人恨。
但长期大家会欣赏。
事情
你最近听谁说他对蠢。
把这个名字逼掉去写。
我就
一直听蠢
而且蠢得始终如一。
他有没有可能是那个对的人呢？
我觉得
他说的话
用poly的话来说。
就是naughty when wrong。
因为不良好定义
你很难说
他说的是对是错
对
就是有一天可能
有一个不一样的范氏发上了。
他就可以跳出来说。
哎
我当年说过这个这个这个这个。
但是你去发现
可能如果范氏是另一种状态。
他也能说一样的话。
这就是我为什么很讨厌这种。
很很贵
很很
很模糊的人的原因。
因为一个事模糊
就是没有意义的
对
你为什么觉得他说他很模糊。
没有真正的定义
就是
是一种模综两可
如果他有正确定义的话。
我可以解释他为什么有正确定义。
但他没有正确定义的话。
我没有办法解释他为什么没有正确定义。
因为他真的没有正确定义。
我觉得像
就是
还是一个很良好定义的事。
就是他他要
他是要做
然后他的方式可能更偏这种。
更更传统的这种
这种new on network的模式。
而不是更
and to end的这种方式。
我觉得这好像是良好定义的。
至于他是对是错
那我觉得是
未来会检验的事情。
对
就大多数老灯其实都还好。
就是我觉得
我觉得人年纪大了。
不一定会变成老灯的。
人年纪大了
会变成两种状态
一种状态叫做得高望重。
就是他会可能
少执手画脚
还会花自己的力气去培养年轻人。
另一种人就是老灯。
就是自己也不懂
还爱执手画脚
所以人老了不一定会变成老灯。
你说受到谁的刺激。
我也不知道我受到谁的刺激。
但我确实见过不少老灯。
你从什么时候变化的。
就是说话非常直接开始。
不收脸了
就是你过去都是这么小的。
但是你不输
我觉得我过去可能。
也会比较直接
但是没有这么直接。
但是做了AI之后就更直接。
是没有束缚是吧？
你什么又束缚
还是这个领域足够客观。
就是
你其实不用太担心。
因为自己的观点是知道什么人。
只要你的观点就是自洽了。
就是你有一套自己观点的理论。
你不是说随便喷人。
那肯定是会惹到原因。
但是你是有一套自己的。
自己的理解
我觉得其实
大家是会尊重你的。
因为最终你在这个领域做的怎么样。
是有客观的评价保证的。
好
我们每个嘉宾都会推荐一本人生之书。
要质本书真的对你产生过重要的影响。
你要说的质本书是什么？
这是今天最难的一个问题。
我感觉你还是高看了我的文化程度。
我真的没有什么人生之书。
说实话
真的没有什么人生之书。
好 最近读了一本书。
最近
上次那个启超说的是。
《县条小狗》
最近读的书就是唐川的自转。
唐川秀书的自转
《旅人》
然后
你要非要说就是可能有印象的书。
首先我这人确实不爱读书。
我感觉就是我这个人文化水平比较低。
然后我读书
除了专业性的书之外。
所有的书感觉都是显书。
像什么唐川的自转。
其实本身也是本显书。
但是就是我觉得显得挺有趣的。
就是
你能看到一个后来看起来。
如此成功的科学家在他年轻的时候。
这种挣扎感
很真实
对
然后
可能就还有一些什么显书。
像小说这个
有本小说我很喜欢。
它的那个
《来自新世界》
是一个日本的小书。
对
我觉得
你要非要让我推荐显书的话。
我可以推荐那个
对
你最近有看什么电影。
什么？
电视剧
玩什么游戏
什么都没有
一个全球范围内
你喜欢的食物
寿司吧？
一个全球范围内
你喜欢的地点
全球范围内喜欢的地点。
我觉得现在你要非要让我选。
我可能会选夏威夷。
因为我很喜欢海
对
但是叶翰南说
因为之后我可能去了更多海的地方。
就另有新欢了
一个少有人知道
但是可能需要知道的知识点。
别相信老登算吗？
你有迷信过吗？
我本质上没有迷信过。
但是我觉得有些时候。
可以靠迷信来安慰自己。
我说你有迷信过老登吗？
迷信老登啊？
从来没有吗？
真的没有
好
但是我以前可能没有这么恨老登。
后来就变得越来越恨老登。
为什么？
可能就是
当你自己有越来越多判断的时候。
那些蠢的人就显得更蠢。
他们也没有伤害你啊？
为什么会恨他呢？
我觉得就是厌蠢症。
每个人都有厌蠢症。
你的NBTR是吗？
不知道
为什么这些年会有一个对于。
就是年轻人对于
年龄大的人
这么不友好的一个词出现了。
在来源在哪里
不知道
没有研究过
可以问问Germany。
让他Depth Research。
一家科学老登那个才是哪儿来的。
那你心目中影响AI进程的一篇论文。
Sequence to Sequence是一篇。
然后那个我觉得是。
Language Model在Feature Engineering。
年轻时代的高峰
然后Screen loss是一篇。
就是主要的Coffin。
他们在OpenEye的那篇Screen loss。
我觉得是一篇
是一篇把这种体系化的研究方式。
引进到这个领域的一篇。
当然最后
实际上Screen loss的做的方法。
可能它那样并不是正确的。
但是是第一篇把这个想法引进来的。
我觉得这很关键
基于你当下的认知一个关键的重要的Bat是什么？
Lang Horizon。
我们工作室叫语言及世界工作室。
第一次听到这个名字的时候。
你在详细的时候
你会发现一个很重要的东西。
语言及世界工作室。
第一次听到这个名字的时候。
你在想什么？
我觉得这个名字有点。
正常的太平庸了
可以
对
其实我觉得这个名字是一个。
可能放在10年以前是一个很。
很独特的视角
现在主要大家共识太多了。
10年以前确实
可能现在不是10年。
对不起我感觉我年纪也大了。
可能不止10年了。
可能在
1415那个年代。
大家都会觉得
视觉是最重要的事。
在那个时候我觉得意识到。
语言是承载智能的重要载体的人。
可能是一个不一样的事情。
不过我觉得我们这个名字。
不是在AR的语境里面讲。
那就值得深思了
好了今天的节目就是这样。
这里是商业访谈录。
是一档由语言及世界工作室出品的。
深度访谈节目
你可以到公众号关注我们的工作室。
获取更多的信息
我们的公众号是
语言及世界
Language is world。
我们希望和你一起。
从这里探索
新的世界